foreign
[Music]
thank you
what's going on
my check my check and all that
seeing my levels are going I see up
today already what's up what's going on
talk to you let me know what I'm saying
I'm trying to mess around with the sound
good Sunday Sunday the Lord's Day
[Music]
what is it sniper
it's a kick David day what's going on no
doubt no doubt oh we got we got live
Supremacy what's going on next what's
going on below what's up and we got a
rifle oh I messed up um Nova bomb for
team ups I'm always busy at Mr live
shows just want to say thanks for all
the great contact I have an awesome one
weekend salute salute salute no doubt
Nintendo under oh Taco five dollars they
are risen shout out to the three Lords
of yo you wild good for confidence I
know happy with Easter to everyone who
celebrates this man really in his
feelings
bro enjoy your game bro like you gotta
let it you gotta let this go you don't
laugh haven't let no man take your joy
cause I don't like you again
what's going on
there's one pint Johnny salute salute
you already know
shout out to the TV already
Easter Sunday scores
[Music]
wow all right I see how people feel
yeah I don't know if that's a problem
here but I'm sure
Lords on the Easter Sunday maybe a
special guest popping through should be
fun
[Music]
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
so
um
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a cannibal and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beating they want to compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all too Dramatical I know
it's random but I'm addicted to flipping
and snapping and making it flammable
this is that this is that Yoga Fire
Flame they think it's Arsen up in the
apartment they call it department and I
get the blame still I'll be running
collecting them Reigns you just a Target
when I'm in the range I was the hardest
to start regardless
check my vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social or my city but I'm still by
Coastal I got it
[Music]
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell a uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
who
let's do that again
foreign
man welcome to the show if you would not
mind go hit it up find yourself a spot
get comfortable grab a snack do all the
good stuff that we need to do in um you
know we're about to get started I am
well it's not important who I am uh
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron Lords podcast right now
as we speaking uh I guess I'm here to
keep you entertained until it's time to
get this show started so um
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a cannibal and they say I'm better
than money because you can Bank on me
being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beating they want to compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all too Dramatical I know
it's random but I'm addicted to flipping
and sampling making it flammable this is
that this is the Yoga Fire Flame they
think it's Arsen up in the apartment
they call it department and I get the
blame still I'll be running collecting
the rains you just a Target when I'm in
the range I was the hardest to start
with regardless and people don't aim
check my vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social or my city but I'm still by
Coastal
[Music]
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell her Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important to who I am uh what's
important is that you are pulling up to
the iron Lords podcast right now as we
speaking uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
damn look y'all messed up and turned me
to an animal and headers be swearing
ain't real but come to find out that
they really mechanical and yeah I'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being a cannibal and they say
I'm better than money because you can
Bank on me being accountable I know a
million rappers that don't want to be on
a song with me that's understandable I
kill a beat and they wanna compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all to Dramatical I know
it's random but I'm addicted to flipping
and Sample and making it flammable this
is that this is that Yoga Fire Flame
they think it's Arsen up in the
apartment they call a department and I
get the blame still I'll be running
collecting them rain you just a Target
when I'm in the range I was the hardest
to start regardless back weed with
messaging people on AIM check my vocals
all on Twitter but I'm anti-social
knowing my city but I'm still by Coastal
[Music]
that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and headers be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a cannibal and they say I'm better
than money because you can Bank on me
being accountable I know a million
rappers they don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beating they want to compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use the video game
just be original y'all too Dramatical I
know it's random but I'm addicted to
flipping and snapping and making it
flammable this is
the Yoga Fire Flame they think it's
arson up in the apartment they call it
department and I get the blame still
I'll be running collecting the rains you
just a Target when I'm in the range I
was the hardest to start regardless back
when you was messaging people on AIM
check my vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social lower my city but I'm still
by Coastal
[Music]
because it's pretty hard to sleep on
Freddy Krueger that's oh
let's do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important to who I am uh what's
important is that you are pulling up to
the iron Lords podcast right now as we
speaking uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
oh
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a cannibal and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on the
song with me that's understandable I
kill a beat and they wanna compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original you're also Dramatical I
know it's random but I'm addicted to
flipping and Snapple and making it
flammable this is that this is the Yoga
Fire Flame they think it's Arsen up in
the apartment they call a department and
I get the blame still I'll be running
collecting the rains you just a Target
when I'm in the range I was the hardest
to start regardless back when you was
messaging people on AIM check my vocals
all on Twitter but I'm anti-social or my
city but I'm still by Coastal
[Music]
because it's pretty hard to sleep on
Freddy Krueger that's
who let's do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a cannibal and they say I'm better
than money because you can Bank on me
being accountable I know a million
rappers they don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beating they want to compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all too Dramatical I know
it's random but I'm addicted to flipping
and snapping and making it flammable
this is that this is that Yoga Fire
Flame they think it's Arsen up in the
apartment they call it department and I
get the blame still I'll be running
collecting the rain you just a Target
when I'm in the range I was the hardest
to start with regardless back when you
was messaging people on AIM check my
vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social or my city but I'm still by
Coastal I got you
[Music]
because it's pretty hard to sleep on
Freddy Krueger that's oh
let's do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot to get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a cannibal and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beating they wanna compare me to Freddie
and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal they'd
be like why use a video game just for
the original y'all too Dramatical I know
it's random but I'm addicted to flipping
and snapping and making it flammable
this is that this is the Yoga Fire Flame
they think it's Arsen up in the
apartment they call it department and I
get the blank
let you know that your dreams are
pursuable whatever you want to do then
it's doable if you got work on a Sunday
it's suitable cause you can listen to
this in your cubicle on the Lord's day
if you got work on a Sunday You're
suitable cause you can listen to this in
your cubicle on the Lord's Day
videos
[Music]
mic check mic check that intro was fired
y'all hear all them boys
that was crazy that was me I told called
you guys don't deserve that wow yo my
check make sure that the rug is good
that's that's attic with the hoodie
spitting box
[Laughter]
yeah good my check if you might check
real quick song
happy Easter and all that and we are
live welcome to the iron Lords podcast
LLC and also live on Lords of gaming.net
episode number two 99
went away from something yeah so first
off I want to be very uh transparent
don't be expecting crazy stuff but we
got some good stuff lined up for 300.
that's crazy we can't expect crazy
because you know how people are that
they they'll expect like huge mag
massive guests it's like look we have we
we have dedicated all of our 300th
episode to the community
yeah
it is I think you guys gonna enjoy it
man I think yeah so it's another
glorious Sunday we're back at the round
table on the Lord's day and today we've
got PlayStation handheld rumors a
competitor to steam deck Sony upset with
the CMA
Joseph stated leaving Microsoft by right
Beastie rise to rumors and ID at Xbox
showcase to discuss so we're gonna get
right into it so let's introduce the
four horsemen the gaming those original
Lords of the realm here at the round
table why are there cars driving when
I'm talking
about co-host with the co-host my
brother for another mother the difficult
game conqueror Lord of his own world and
the how of the young wolf my man Lord
addict of the attic show how we doing
son I'm pretty good uh first off I want
to appreciate everyone for uh supporting
us on the reactions uh patreon in
general guys are pulling up there pretty
strong you know we got solved reacting
to uh Ryan Goku versus I'm not even
going to butcher his name uh but it's
it's it's the uh it's the third uh demon
and uh Demon Slayer why did you seem to
cause the yes a lot of you seem to enjoy
that so we're going to be doing more of
that you know
eventually I call again on the uh on the
music stuff you know working with him on
that yeah my Green Day yeah and I want
to I want to you know shout out to Mario
yeah I'm gonna make this very quick guys
need to go watch it they did a fantastic
job with just about everything I don't
know what the critics at Hollywood are
on I think that's mainly because there
are a lot of them probably ain't like
Gamers and they didn't really pick up a
lot of the Easter eggs that was in it uh
but it is what it is they voted that I'm
telling you not to look at that and just
go watch it uh because we can't scream
for these people to stay true to the to
the script and then you gamers don't
show up
um
it surpasses
these Gamers showed up so you these they
showed up with a game dedicated to the
gamers so you need to go watch that
movie and that's all I'm pretty much
gonna say no doubt no doubt Mario out
there cosine it's good it's really
really good RNR with the Lord's Tuesday
at 5pm
No Doubt
and of course we have our most tactical
gaming Lord the solo gamer list for the
single player selfish experience and
also that's ostradamus the Lord of
clarity and Lord patreon of the iron
bank newly PC Master race Lord Sovereign
how are we doing sir
ah do it a little bit under the weather
a little little uh you know sounding a
little finicky here welcome to the club
a little something as a spring you know
arrives you know New York weather change
yes
31 day and like you know whatever it's
70 the next yeah the next day whole new
outfit the next day instantly sick yep
facts
[Laughter]
saw Mario yesterday oh nice
enjoyed it a lot and despite you know
hacking up along during most of the
third most of the movie but um took lady
Sav to go see it um the niece and the
nephew as well the first time they got
they went to go to iPic so they were
excited oh you took it to their boat
they were like I said I said yeah press
that button right there yeah
press the Smithers button and beasts
yeah more comfortable seating than a
person that comes and waits on me and
yeah yeah you got used to that button
Don't Front yeah
it was nice I just I I really like the
seating arrangements that was at that
one in Boston like it was really yeah
Boston was nice well yeah because Adobe
Vision Dolby sound yeah and they had
seats built for people like me oh for
Big Boy seats okay okay yeah um so yeah
it was good it was a good time uh we I
think we got a new waiter so he kind of
messed up orders a little bit and got
sent over gotta we got our food a little
bit later than it was expected but over
what happens
[Laughter]
so he brought me I said Shaker this is
how he wasn't a great waiter but I
appreciate him because he appreciate it
he actually cut one of the things off
the off the uh bill because of this
horrid service yeah continue so he
brings me just a cup of it and I'm like
I said Shaker and he's oh oh my bad I'm
sorry I'll be back I'm like I'm not
Drake
you always get a Shaker anybody who goes
I pick get a Shaker of anything that
you're gonna drink because getting one
cup of it is just ridiculous it's like
ten dollars off the price of the Shaker
so just get the Shaker yeah
mean that that enjoyed the movies good
time
um and this week I just played some
Resident Evil 4
um bro it's I I'm really enjoying it it
is
the only thing my beef with it is that
they made him so heavy like when he's
running he looks like he's weighed down
by like a thousand pounds even at his
top speed he's like he's still heavy and
that's how they add to the you know the
the suspense and the fact that they have
more um you know enemies coming at you
but I'm like why is this this Elite
agent so heavy
but I get it I get it but but overall
I'm really enjoying it because that's
what I've been playing with the Gears of
War levels uh you know yeah yeah yeah
anyway no doubt and of course we have
the Incredible Hulk of this aka the XS
gamer who the prophet of Xbox Swami King
of the statues who demands nothing less
than that premium experience and is the
leader of the fraud alert movement oh
beloved Lord King how are we doing sir
I'm doing better than uh Javier fontuna
he got knocked out yesterday Mendoza
gave him that oh we dropped them knocked
them out got him out of there she called
Stevenson uh walked over his duck uh
Keyshawn Johnson I mean Keyshawn Davis
walked over his duck
um top ring Fighters y'all be thinking
y'all be out there doing it Barbarian be
serving y'all up ducks and then you're
getting fight real dudes and get your
headphones also y'all know what it is
um UFC was fighting yesterday I didn't
get a chance yes
I thought he heard was a good uh is he
good match
um
Super Mario Brothers okay let's get it
the reason why the Rotten Tomato scores
is what it is and pardon my voice I'm
underweather
Disney is bombarding them right they
trying to keep those uh the ratings low
so dudes would be like nah I ain't gonna
go see that it already surpassed their
greatest movie so far and it's on its
way be frozen it'd be frozen too Frozen
one I mean Frozen two be frozen one
girl and that was domestically so this
is a sh I'm trying to watch it Tuesday
yeah no we win we're not gonna spoil
anything okay I'm just gonna say you're
in for the greatest treat as a fan and
if you were there from the 80s yeah man
everything yes everything everything
just just look all the way yeah
everything listen for listen for
everything look at everything it is it
is fan service to the max my old model
was there he was there putting things
here and there Easter eggs all over it's
probably like a billion Easter eggs but
this week I was playing Seafood shout
out to the the know wonderful friends of
the podcast the my brothers
I got to this point I recorded so many
um I got to a point when I was going
down a hole down the hallway
which hallway was it it was was it the
3D hallway or the one that turned
sideways we want to go sideways okay
that was two-dimensional and it was like
so this one dude he thought he was going
to catch me because he got the glow in
his hands I buried his glow punched him
in the face picked up the blade off the
floor I took him out of there it felt so
good now I'm at a point right now with
this lady who likes to throw this um
chain yes
bro I turned it off why you why you
didn't I turned it off because I said
today I'm not gonna be frustrated you
got there at 20 years old they left that
80.
yeah I got there at 30 years old and I'm
47 years old
fighting this woman the other one with
the kunai it was no problem she threw
the Kona I caught the kunai
not this one bro it's a dope game you
know of course fortnite and that's about
it chilling no no salute that you salute
to you and of course we have the game
religion himself there should no be
Lloyd Cognito spread that realness in
the room and IOP not telling what you
want to hear but what you need to hear
shout out to Friday dude shout out to
Dustin with some of the best thumbnails
in the game
Dominican Barrett Bobby
hey look he looked like a brolic Romeo
Santos
yo shout out to that's they got me
outside anytime you're gonna start
saying sucker
the Mr T out here yeah that James was
crazy check us check us out we just talk
about uh if uh Playstation is blocking
um XBox games it was kind of a funny
topic so we had dad um shout out to
Bautista the last word Travis actually
bought this is on a vacay right now but
he was able to do a last word with us
catching up at all sandbox updates all
that good stuff
um as far as me yes Seafood as well or
midnight sun's been going hard finish
the Mobius uh Quest now and I'm just
leveling people up Destiny getting my
raid in them a lot of Destiny actually
and yeah oh yeah yeah I'm gonna tell you
right now I didn't watch the movie yeah
the midnight Sun's voice actor I heard
the midnight Sons voice actors are so
good and when you as the hunter who
knows nothing about them is ask them
because well how about your powers what
does this mean what's the living vampire
you like a vamp like the way they break
it down like makes me love the character
I'm like yo I want to kind of know about
him now but now y'all gotta be scared
everybody say the movie this movie is oh
look yeah the movie is not all that
great yeah the characters he's one of my
favorites yeah yeah yeah so we got that
I've been rocking that and then real
quick um Izzy Izzy yo Israel all lasagna
um I ain't gonna lie before for a little
[__]
I thought she was gonna get destroyed
because the reason why is Alex Pereira
he's a he's a beast he he does the
kickboxing he's been a dominant person
he's literally your mirror but bigger
and shut up but the thing is usually you
know I go King
we've been there for the twos the the
Roy Tarver twos the Vernon Forest sugar
shape like usually there's that dude
that skill set Wise It's just that guy
did this guy beat you like three times
his son did all this so in my mind I was
like yeah that's probably gonna be the
breaking down you know I'm saying it's
gonna be the breakdown and it's sad
because I like Izzy so I was like
first he was kind of tentative but there
was a moment he just said you know that
effort moment I gotta stay in the pocket
and I'm not scared of you because let's
be able to do the stalking you bigger
dude stalk you anyway got him to the
case and it looked spooky but he held up
and he just you know you bite the teeth
down yeah and he just caught him he
stretched his but he got he had one of
the most disrespectful
finishing I dated you celebrations with
the arrow bro oh my God the fact that he
thought about what he was gonna do and
visualized his greatness salute to him
one of the best um speeches I've ever
heard at the end of the match you
couldn't get them all then he even got
the sun back he got the sun back
remember the sun was cleaning him yeah
he did this this is lean this flawless
Fallout knockout thing yeah yeah he was
a little kid little kid seven years old
yeah yeah yeah no no it was paid back no
it was all like all Izzy look at your
daddy now yeah look at him now yo I was
so proud of him on that and I I got it I
wasn't a Believer he did at absolutely I
I was I was a Believer because I in
every fight Izzy was it has been beaten
again yeah it's a matter of is he
getting tired
going up against the cage yeah and
getting caught and and you know once you
get tired you make mistakes right in
this case same thing kind of thing
happened is he was in his face in the
pocket I was like okay he's not afraid
of him he's willing to exchange just do
not put your back against that's great
yeah he did he did but he [__] down he
hurt his leg and then Izzy started
moving back and you really don't move
back is if you move back you don't he's
too much of a stalker he's gonna set up
a lot of little of little pockets for
him to attack you and he was in a you
know same as the the way the first fight
ended was the same thing oh no yeah
hands up yeah and but he was he was he
was awake this time because he knocked
out on his feet yep and he just caught
him right on the temple one time with a
counter punch through the equilibrium
off and it just came right right back
punched is he just doing here yeah oh he
needed that hammerfist for his soul that
was the dear Henderson I got it I gotta
take you up out of here I gotta get you
a body here I gotta kill you so I gotta
say uh because to lose three times to
somebody the Lesser Fighters yeah lesser
Fighters were just he's just in your
head and that's right no matter what
correct and the uh he did it so now I
don't know that that it if they fight
again I don't know her prayer is going
up he can't be going up yeah that's what
they said uh yeah that makes sense too
he would be man uh he's taking his wins
he leaving yeah
let's move on because attic falls asleep
[Laughter]
so real quick so we got that no IOP pole
lash I forgot I had we had the technical
issue so I forgot apologies on Cog we
will make it right this week with a new
poll question which will have results
we'll do that
um we do have a patreon question should
we do the patreon question or do you
want to do the super chats now do the
patreon question all right patreon
question for us right now
um and I'm not gonna put you the name so
I'm not gonna try it but I'm gonna
listen to the to the video you sent me
you know who you are and I'm gonna get
your name pronunciation correct cause
I'm not solved with the new of another
canceled E3 and PAX East under our belts
it got me thinking what would it look
like if XBox hosted an event similar in
a similar vein to the 360 Zero Hour it
doesn't have to be a console launched
specifically A celebratory event APK
deal goes through or Xbox celebrates
happy games again who cares pick a
reason what does that event look like do
people show is it less pop more less or
more popular now than it was before does
it pop off and turn into Microsoft
versions of Burning Man in the middle of
the desert curious about the Lord's
thoughts on a console specific game
Festival anybody can get it
Microsoft won't do it because uh
financially they realize that they can
do little tiny events with controlled
scenes and make it look like giant
events and still control the narrative
and save money so nothing like that
happened
my thoughts on an advance off yeah I
mean
they've done stuff like that for console
launches I can see something cool like
that I remember the event out in the
desert I think it was for the 360 launch
or something like that out in like an
airplane Hangar or something that's
years ago when people were spending
money when people spending that type of
money I just think the landscape is
different like King said it's like
there's no need to spend that amount of
money to get the message out and still
see the same results or even better
results right so I don't see it I would
love to do it because
what worries me about E3 going away even
though there's still taxes and we really
enjoy paxes but it is that event that
industry event is going to bring
everybody together in a big way because
unfortunately what happens is throughout
the industry you're going to see the
bigger Publishers shy away from from
that sort of stuff the smaller guys
still need that Spotlight on them so
they're going to make the time to go to
a packs they're going to make the time
to go to these smaller events because
they're not charging them as much as and
stuff like that so unfortunately the big
event that's that is sort of encompassed
by big games I don't know we're gonna
see as much of it so for something that
size you need a bunch of big games to
sort of promote that and I don't know if
that's going to happen so I wish it were
true and stuff like that would happen I
just don't know the reality is is where
we're at no doubt addict thoughts big
event
I personally me selfishly I don't want
anything like ether to go away I want
them to you know go above and beyond but
the only reason people need to go above
and beyond was because everyone else was
there I think if individual Publishers
are making their own event they don't
need to go above and beyond because
they're the only people there it's not
like you know when you're doing E3 and
you feel like you have to compete with
PlayStation so you go bigger than you
think they're gonna go like
you're picking the date you can
literally go anytime you want so you're
going to go when PlayStation's not there
so you don't have to go as big because
you don't have anyone else around you
that's going to soak up that news time
yeah no I hear you I think I'll just
jump in on I'm all about Xbox doing more
events because I feel like with all the
Acquisitions is getting to the point now
you can't name your show the Xbox but
that's the Activision yeah right you're
gonna say like you can't do it so the
console specific stuff I think is what
you said like I think they can basically
control the narrative by having their
own pop-up show you know but not not in
person
but like you know what I'm saying
through online and if they do it online
you can you know you can do your hey
we're celebrating activation hey we're
sitting down with Robert but we're
sitting down with Mikey Barra from
blizzard and you know tell us what
happens now that kind of stuff so I
think that's kind of the deal um yeah
I'm not I'm not against in-person events
you know what I'm saying I'm not against
it but I just think it makes more
financial sense at this point based on
what happened with the esa and E3 for
them not to do that so that's where I'm
at let's get this super chest man
oh hell the Lords Sony Fanboys are
coming out from under the rock to talk
about how red fall looks but you hating
from the outside the club you you you
can get in you can't get it so you can't
get it good I mean you you can't you
don't want to get in but you can't
that's maybe a different thing
everybody's welcome in this club
hilarious then we got Nintendo the otaku
five dollar Super Chat they are risen
chill
[Laughter]
also happy Easter to everyone who
celebrates thank you brother appreciate
it
really big man he ain't like I waited on
his tears of the Kingdom you're not
feeling it yeah we have Nintendo Dio
Taco once again five dollars to a chat
reminder that Nintendo will have game of
the year and the biggest movie of the
year 2023. movie the movie for sure for
moving what I'm hearing is for sure yeah
it does we have B Lou remember for 19
months Lord bronze shout out to Awards
hey Saul I know you want to be here a
little bit Our Guest is here uh I'll
finish the super chats after you leave
cool okay I mean cool so you oh you want
to just do all right that's perfect let
me finish this last one shout out shout
out to the Lord's salute to Izzy for
reclaiming an epic fashion also shippur
is amazing y'all keep killing it no
doubt
is the next one
is that the legendary is that The
Insider
let's see if we can hear him he's
unmuted okay oh yes
Lord Tom can you can you hear us sir
yeah yeah yeah uh congratulations yes I
hear you the legendary you know what a
survival of your kid you remember like
the the guy like don't don't get tickets
Broadway child like the guy that
snitched they got you know they got the
voice over you just hear the voice you
hit a soldier boy it tells you all the
inside information
they got him behind the behind the curve
we need the voice modulator we need the
voice modulator I did see the UFOs
no Tom Tom doesn't have on his camera
because remember I took his eyebrows oh
my God
a little bit absolute pleasure for you
to make it man we're gonna get right
into it because we gotta respect Saul's
top obviously obviously at your time so
uh yeah yeah uh some big news that you
broke this week uh Playstation handheld
man codename cue light you know the next
piece of Sony Hardware you had a lot of
stuff to say reference to that so just
for those who are unaware of this
amazing you know uh kind of news you
broke on inside gaming you know tell
people what's the thought process here
as far as uh slowly stinking and then um
how this may relate to the PlayStation 5
Pro
man so I think in terms of
um this even being successful straight
away is
it's gonna need to be cheap right
um and and that's why I'm looking
forward to King's predictions
yeah it's going to need to be cheap it's
going to use a remote play
um instead of like traditional clothes
so
um yeah I mean that's pretty much it
um I did say in the report it is going
to release between the PlayStation 5 Pro
which is the end of 2014 at the moment
and between the
um new PlayStation 5 which is going to
have a detachable disk drive towards the
end of this year
um
but yeah I at the moment at this moment
in time it is going to release towards
the end of this year so a lot of people
said it's going to be 2024
um but at the moment it's it's looking
like November wow
one with Ken to speculate time that this
seems to be then whatever the next Sony
showcase should be should be huge
because you're talking about a lot of
Hardware reveals I mean it's your face
King I'm just laughing they putting out
all this Hardware with no games
excuse me sir anyway no because
you out of pocket anyway so basically
you know we knew about the detachable
District like you said um you know then
you said there's a project no man what I
believe is like wireless earphones is
that correct um
yeah and those are also coming towards
the end of the year so yeah whatever
whatever this uh next your guess is
going to be it seems like it is going to
be
um a pretty big one uh I know I know
Grubb said that it was going to be like
the next
Affairs of of PlayStation which it seems
like it is going to be
um but but I mean we've got to see some
games so
um it's going to be interesting yeah
yeah very interesting because again
you're talking about like a a very
serious Hardware rollout and then if
that's this year and then potentially
again according to your sources
potentially A PS5 Pro are we thinking
holiday 2024 what do we think in PS5 Pro
stop laughing
yeah at the moment it's uh holiday 24.
um
obviously with with the things that go
on with development that could be pushed
back but I would expect that we could
hear probably about the pro
the next Shockers which we could expect
to be summertime next year or whatever
it's going to be okay okay sovere what's
your thoughts because I know your time's
limit is off I wanted to get your
thoughts here like what are you thinking
about all this with you know this
Hardware a a PlayStation handheld does
this appeal to you where you're at with
all this up I mean for me personally I
I've always no matter how good my
internet connection is and my home
connection is super good I've never had
an experience that I kind of consider to
be acceptable for me in terms of either
just cloud gaming or even sort of uh you
know what's it called the uh
what's the PlayStation version called of
it the uh oh you talk about like the one
remote play or roleplay yeah like I've
just never it's it's never when I try to
do it on the video whatever I just never
had a great experience with it with vita
there was other limitations whereas the
control schemes weren't the same and
stuff like that and needed to use the
back whatever button thing so for me
it's just interesting that again we saw
this recent uh release with the uh what
the heck is the other one that came out
for that that is the Logitech gcloud the
Logitech right the gcloud I mean I saw
that I said who is this for and you know
obviously it it did what it did and
certain people love it but um for me
this thing that's an extent I I agree
wholeheartedly with creating a machine
that is an extension of that ecosystem
and allows you to to make the ecosystem
completely fluid right
where I don't see the benefit is if it
is a pricey
cloud-based Remote Play based thing
that's going to technically give you an
inferior experience for whatever x
amount of dollars they want to charge
you for it I would have preferred
they invest wholeheartedly in making
something stronger
locally right that allows you to play
the games locally natively give me give
me you know a PS4 Pro level sort of
power wise right
and the prices
that's a lot to ask about that it is a
lot to ask for but I'm not asking for
separate games right okay I want
something just like a steam that's an
extension of that ecosystem that allows
me to take it anywhere I want this thing
I don't know how appealing it is to
everyone again it has to do with you
know
here we go it sounds like a possible l
in the making unless behind the scenes
you know the the guts of it behind you
know it's working to a point where the
experience is excellent if that is the
case cool I can see you know we've
talked about Microsoft with this doing
something like this or whatever
um I just to me I see the benefit in
creating the powerful portable that
extends the ecosystem and lets you play
those games locally as opposed to it
constantly having to be connected in
some way shape or form I just don't I
don't think we're there yet they keep
making putting these machines out in an
environment where that isn't the norm
yet it sounds like a PSP Go don't it
yeah yeah PSP Go to the bushes
so for me it's that it's I don't think
we're there yet where it's viable to
sell in a world where they just sold me
a 550 dollar headset it's more expensive
console I don't I I fear that
PlayStation isn't going to read the room
and charge me an excessive amount of
money for this thing that is a
essentially a cloud extension of their
ecosystem rather than a bespoke bangers
you're gonna have to get in there so I
don't I don't know I I to me it doesn't
make a whole lot of sense so so we'll
see yeah so nothing helps you no there's
nothing right now that would move you
it's not it's not local I don't need it
it's fine and this is as a guy who can't
play his PlayStation unless he's home
and he's never home right I just don't
you know for me at work I don't have the
greatest internet so it doesn't work a
whole well got you got you so it would
have to be I I would want the bespoke
local you know machine that is powerful
enough for those games to look decent at
that resolution at that size so again
and I would be willing to pay me maybe
an exorbitant money
so yeah I think that's special though is
how many people are willing to pay that
right and you know just because you got
certain people do that because you got
to keep them on the competing with uh
with the steam bag right they're
competing with whatever the successors
on the on on the switch because we know
that's happening eventually right the
successor on the switch can they compete
in that Market if the price is too
priced out you know and I think it's
it's debatable at that point and
especially
no no but that's the thing I worry about
them price wise no matter what the
machine is if it was a if it was a a
local machine like a steam deck or
whatever the price would be crazy so I
just worry that the price is going to be
crazy anyway so Tom I don't know if you
know about your sources but uh what
about that what if a nice little sweet
300 or 300 or less unfortunately I
wasn't able to get it was a perfect
today
but what I will say is that I think that
we all set ourselves up for
disappointment with this
um
with like the Asus Ally there was rumors
that they're making that to compete with
a new PlayStation handheld and all of
this kind of stuff so I think we just
set ourselves up for disappointment but
I think if you if you look at the Q
light as an accessory and not a handheld
then things start to change a little bit
um by the end of this year there's
probably going to be 45 to 50 million
PlayStation fives on the market right so
so already they have the accessory to
complement that market right
um and if if this is gonna be 150 to 200
because essentially it is it is just
going to be it's a nice place time I
like that 152.
well do you think that's realistic
though Tom like do you think that in in
the market today is realistic
I think around 200 would be realistic
because essentially all this is is the
Dual sense
I'm assuming it's gonna have a touch
screen on it it's going to be 399. what
the Dual Sense Technology in it like I
do I I feel like 252.99 it's going to be
399 dollars
y'all can ride it on the wall we better
top again listen I agree with King on
this one oh wait wait y'all think they
gonna charge three though
a street
[Music]
but remember you said this I didn't
I'm telling you
3.99 that's that's bad I know this is
3.99 because we're never going to shut
King up I know these days like the back
of my hand I told you that that uh that
psvr was going to be six surprise
who's here yeah so um you said you said
the psvr is going to be a thousand
dollars no I said it's 12 100 you got to
add in that PlayStation five I was dead
on boom that happened
that was there so we ain't gonna act
like I ain't been right on price I just
know these dudes and I know they don't
care about y'all so y'all all be sitting
out there talking about these low
numbers yeah three notches since you're
talking about bats and stuff Tom I got a
question for you real quick uh do you
got any uh insight and knowledge on
whether or not that Spider-Man 2
Wolverine is going to be Playstation
four or five oh Lord here we go no I
don't
uh
being a king we we have a little you
know bend the knee going on that I'm
saying both of those games are gonna be
PlayStation 5 only and keep saying
they're gonna be crossbones I'm saying
as soon as this ABK deal go through
everything's off the desk everything and
we getting all the money we can get and
you scared to death right now because
you keep asking about questions about a
game let the game come out let it do
what it's gonna do that's it stop stop
running to everybody looking for a shirt
I'm trying to get him I'm trying to get
I'm trying to get my my flowers now
what I want you to do is get that shea
butter for them knees you know it's
gonna be funny car I already know what's
gonna happen what's good they're gonna
announce this for PlayStation five
people like I need to see the game come
out
for PlayStation 5. the Dead come out Jim
Ryan gonna say and for my PlayStation 4
users we didn't leave you behind
you can download it right now digitally
watch you and I'm gonna say see I told
you it wasn't worth it so like okay get
your balls off on this topic so what do
you think about this the cute light
PlayStation handheld Tom Henderson
inside game and broke the story it's
it's a stupid handheld yo it is
all right so what are you saying I'm
playing on my PlayStation I got to get
up and go to the toilet hold on let me
go grab this little thing because I
gotta be on the same Wi-Fi as this
stupid little thing and I gotta go to
the bathroom or
I'm gonna play on my PlayStation 5 and I
want to sit on the deck and watch the
children while they play and I'm just
outside in the sun this is for who who
want to play on the same Wi-Fi in their
house it Remote Play hasn't been good
it's not a good thing it's a passion
part this sounds like another passion
project somebody up there and Sony is
running passion projects like that
detachable
uh what you call a disk drive on a
PlayStation what is wrong with you who's
green lighting needs things and all I
I'm happy that is happening
because remember when Sego started green
lighting a whole bunch of dumb stuff
like oh this is the beginning
they green lighted the VR the green
light at the handheld the green lighted
the the 3DX attack the detachable joint
this big green light and remember what
was that joint called it was the the
console with the CD on the green light
is so much stuff they went bankrupt
right why because they were selling to a
market that nobody wanted it nobody
wants this I don't hear nobody here
saying yo yeah man I can't wait to get a
hold of that
3.99 no and you're gonna have you guys a
cap out there talking about yeah Sony
coming out with you y'all didn't even
bother VR why because the VR they
announced two million I was gonna ship
they cut that by a million and then
after now they talk about we're gonna
cut that by 20 bro y'all not enough
y'all not out there supporting y'all not
buying VR you're not gonna buy this
handheld they're not gonna buy the
detachable baby units
that's right there to say yo let me get
a portable stomach
let's decide nah man listen
somebody's running y'all into the ground
trying to destroy Sony eternity within
with passion projects bro
and who who looked at this device to say
are we sure Phil Harrison isn't working
there so much
I'm just saying 3.99 Tom
um I believe so and it is what it is
we'll see look but they they never let
me down
but I'm just gonna say look all right I
hear y'all I hear y'all you know the
price point is going to be everything on
whatever this thing is gonna be
um for me personally you know look
Loki I might be interested King I know
it's gonna surprise you but it's just
like look we know Nix is the steam deck
and everything's coming to PC right but
there is something to be said about
playing your entire PlayStation 5
library on the go and let's keep it a
buck the PS5 is one of the most
beastiest you know it's a monstrosity of
a console to be carrying around it's a
murder weapon yeah like like no one's
lugging hey guys I'm bringing it over
no one's doing it with that console I do
not like the size of that console it's
just ridiculous to me so you know and I
gotta be real I am a Vita dude I used
remote play a lot the problem with said
Vita was always this was the only
weakness to this thing with the 3G the
fact that you had to do this this right
here this little molester yeah that's
horrible which didn't have yeah which
didn't have the extra shift this is
where switch destroys them this single
shift right here was they didn't have
the form factor to replicate True full
controller functionality remember the
analogs also didn't push in remember
these these were not buttons like how it
is today so we lost they try to map
everything to this and this was not it
that was the only witness so which
switch is superior to them right which
had the causal effect so all I'm saying
is look I hear y'all sorry I hear you
native device and the fact that they
made the Vita it's like damn come on
Sony invest y'all did this before I'm
with y'all my thing is though
if you're telling me I can still remote
in and according to Tom right if it's
like 250 the less
some people may look it depends let's
say the device looks slick
let's say if it's a really slick looking
thing for the 200 and it's like yo you
somewhere else you can remote and now
granted I'm with you we can't do this on
your seller trade we can't do this at
the airport I feel you the functionality
limiting is ridiculous but let's just
say you know SOB's going over he's
leaving right now he's about to go you
know Easter family thing they're getting
on his nerves you know internet is okay
yeah we get a couple trophies done
I say this though right but uh I saw a
Kai doing it with uh with his steam deck
yeah and and it worked super well on the
same day I was surprised at the frame
rate or everything like that again so it
there's a possibility there but the use
case scenarios and and the circumstances
that have to be just right for it to
work it's just one of those things where
I just think like you said it's very
limiting it's very limiting and for me
none of those circumstances ever come
into play
with any sort of regularity so that's
just it for me
relying on internet for a product to be
worth the amount of money that they're
asking for three minutes of sell it's a
tough sell yeah and that's it yeah so
I'll be good I think the odds of
something like this succeeding it just
depends on how well they support it I
personally feel like the only way that
PlayStation is able to really capitalize
is they have to use their first party
studios in different ways and they've
currently done it if you look at stuff
like the Vita you know their core thing
was we're gonna we're gonna have the
people that make our AAA titles make
those games in a portable different kind
of scenario and I think that was the
wrong approach 100 look look at Nintendo
when Nintendo does stuff they're like
look we're gonna make games that you
could easily pause and you could pick up
again in a couple hours like we're gonna
make very easily portable games Pokemon
animal uh Crossing there's they they
have capitalized a Mario Kart you know
they capitalize these type for games
that to me the only way it's going to
work is if you know PlayStation goes out
to all their Studios and they're like
look we need you to make more accessible
portable games so we can put on these
new platforms but I don't think they're
going to do that this is exactly what
we're going to do they're going to walk
up King they're gonna look them up like
we want you to make PlayStation 5 games
we also want you to make PlayStation VR
games and we also want you to make sure
all that snap works on this portable
device that we got it's just a stream
enjoy they don't even got to configure
for it yeah they have to make a new SKU
for it you know I get what you like what
you're saying though but I do want to
ask Tom like like before this last but
no we move on from the subject like just
like what what's your thoughts on this
like as far as like the viability maybe
the potential or is there something
we're not seeing you know that you say
hey you know what this could work with
their ego so just what's your personal
thoughts on this potential rollout
because they look like they're linking
this with this you know this other
Hardware as well as PS5 Pro eventually I
I think it's only viable depending on
the price and that's it and that's it
um
towards the end of the year with this
new console which with the disk drive
I'm assuming it's going to be just like
the regular price of the PS5 at the
moment like 500 if this
handheld is gonna just be an accessory
and it's going to be 150 and then you
bundle you bundle that with the
PlayStation 5 for 650 maybe throw in
Spider-Man 2 for 700. you thought I'd be
in a package it with a Spider-Man song
and you give it in the Box song If you
if they're a most expensive accessory
now apart from the psvr 2 headset is
that whatever that that dual sense Edge
controller at almost 200 if you could
hit that price point or was it almost
200 it's just it is 200 actually yeah
exactly
so if you could hit that price point or
below
100 I can see the liability so so check
it out all right so I'm tired of hearing
y'all and then we got an entire finish
okay and it's funny I know I'm a little
time for it all right it's just a
firsthand help no not not at all right
no no right did they do all those stuff
that y'all said they was going to do the
last time with the last handheld pretty
much they stopped supporting right but
they stopped supporting because they had
to build separate games for it and they
got hacked
they were never going to support it that
way that's why we look at the psvr too
we're like oh because it you see you see
the similarities this is different in
that it really is just the price point
thing because even if it sucks if the
price point is right no I don't trust
you thank you that's that's all true a
lot of money for it I'm just listen I'm
getting to the point where y'all y'all
keep acting like these dudes have ever
done anything nice
but my thing is you just you're
comparing it it's literally apples and
oranges because you're comparing it to
what I want to as a bespoke give me give
me something that has Hardware in it
don't let Saul talk to you like that
listen even even the PSP Go you was able
to download it to the hardware right
right but that was actual Hardware so so
now you got this little thing right now
because this is somebody's passion
project they looked over and said your
streaming is the wave we're gonna do
this right here and we're gonna give
them PlayStation a flavor it's gonna be
3.99
I know in a perfect world you would love
to run in the store pick up the the
PlayStation 5 get the accessory like you
call it it's not it's Hardware right
they want that but what if they pocket
in the Box though they're not pocketing
nothing
top finished
I am so sorry because you're going to be
sending me this thing so
Tom you're gonna lose this bet to kick
is
it's going to be packaged with the
PlayStation 5. I I but I I I don't think
that this is gonna be
um a handheld where Sony a gonna report
sales figures and stuff like that it's
it's just gonna be an accessory
accessory so wait wait yeah I said y'all
ain't gonna report salesman all right
y'all are wowing right now you you said
the guy that only talks about his
numbers okay is not gonna report numbers
on the hill I know and I don't and Tom I
know you saying this it's not a handheld
right and it's okay your sauce is right
the joint is coming The Source Who if he
floated you the number oh it's gonna be
there now this is one thing this is one
thing we haven't talked about right now
to me
this is where this is where
they're kind of shooting themselves at
the foot a little bit by making it like
this and maybe there's no other way of
doing it by not making it a cloud
streaming device just a Remote Play
device you're forced to have to have a
PlayStation 5 right yeah you have to
have a PlayStation that's true that's
true that's true so then that again that
additional cost if it is excessive makes
it unappealing at Tom's point I don't
know man brand new hardware however much
of an accessory or an extension of it I
just don't I don't Jimmy gonna look at
them like nope we're not giving them
that for free what about this Mr PC
raspberry all right I feel you you're
right with the ecosystem lock that you
would have to remote play into
PlayStation but what about I mean they
have been embracing PC more so Tom do
you think Last of Us Part One is a
private job
besides part one the majority of their
games have functioned very well there
will be any cross-functionality with
this device if but their potential PC
ports no no damn no they see that from
from what I've seen is pure live
PlayStation five
[Music]
so I mean things can things can change
as as it starts to materialize a bit
more but from what I've seen it's Remote
Play Only yeah it's going to be funny
Tom Tommy say that he's already won this
bet because he saw the promotion with
them
Hey listen listen check it out so when
they did the they slashed the forecast
numbers on the PlayStation VR Jim walked
in the room and said somebody gonna have
to pay for this
somebody's gonna have to pay for this so
he was like yo we was gonna shoot he's
like and it ain't going to be me this
thing at 199. so he said yo so if we if
we push it to 399 we're gonna make our
money back off of this VR that's busted
yeah yo all right so what we're gonna do
we're gonna put it for three minutes
removal in this way and then when we do
a price drop for Black Friday for fifty
dollars they still think they're getting
over they not I cannot wait for the 399
to hit and I'm just gonna walk out
through I'm not going to say anything
I'm just gonna walk out the room that's
gonna be it for the podcast for today
next time I'll be like thank you
and that's it because I know Sony want
their money back
it's okay Tom don't don't waver because
King is is famous for making bets off of
emotion he's famous I didn't say
anything I was minding my business and
he said yo if if it's 3.99 I'll buy you
one well thank you
and I you listen I would do a live
unboxing oh my Lord look real quick we
got to talk about the other competitive
ring which is the final part of this
topic yeah you got to go soft do your
things
pleasure my apologies for having to
leave but uh my wife will kill me yes
so yeah the rock rock Ally you know what
I'm saying ASUS
ASUS whatever
um seven inch 16x9 display no 1080p
resolution 500 nits of brightness 120
hertz refresh rate which is compared to
steam deck which listens at a 16 by 10
which is 1912 80 by 800 only 400 nits
and 60hz refresh rate the chip um inside
the Rog Ally it uses AMD Zen 4
architecture with the powerful rdna3
Graphics Tech seen in recent GPU so it
looks like some people do have their
hands on it you know at least on a
prototype level so uh yeah let's start
with time man I mean obviously we're
talking handhelds I figure this be you
know cool to have you get your thoughts
on it you know do you look at this as a
viable steam deck competitor are there
anything that interests you about this
device just what's your thoughts of the
early impressions of what we're hearing
about this device
no nothing interests me about it because
I'd rather just buy the steam deck
I don't know it's just I don't know just
nothing is screaming
by me with with what the
with it so yeah
um I don't know I think we're probably
gonna see a few more competitors come
into the market over the course of the
next couple of years so it's going to be
interesting to see how that plays out
but yeah I I at this moment in time I'll
just go for a steam deck I think that a
lot of people who want a handheld have
probably already gone for the steam deck
um so it yeah it's fair enough fairly
yeah I just can't see
people [__] out another five six
hundred dollars five six for the
baseball that they're promoting like
what double the performance yeah six
hundred dollars take a six okay okay
potential potential let's get addict
Lord of our handheld here um thoughts
you know on a steam deck competitor I
don't know if you got a chance to look
at the Ally
I'd rather watch Shazam again oh my God
Jesus no no no no no Steve deck love no
Ally love no hair that love is he got
Pokemon oh we talk about the gigs okay
okay Finn well I gotta see stuff he like
you know I don't mind you know I might
throw Jabs at the steam death but at
least you have your esteem library to
gravitate towards does this
you know access any type of Library like
a PlayStation library or something what
is this actually well I mean it looks
like you could obviously it feels like
Windows 11
um you can put Steam you know the OS on
that
um there are rumors of um Xboxes
so just to clarify I got to pay six
seven hundred dollars
yet we don't know the price yet but one
could assume the rumors are they they
are advertising with the AMD I mean the
Zen 4 and rdna3 they are advertising
they are double the power of steam deck
so we just assuming based on these
proclamations and what is it lightest
Tech technique and what's my man Dave
Tudy who's who have these prototype
units and they're running these games at
the High High Fidelity
um one could assume that the base might
be in that pocket you know maybe five
maybe six I feel like because the steam
deck I feel like we're gonna get flooded
with these handheld things and some are
going to succeed some are not going to
succeed I think the reason the steam
deck yeah I think the reason the steam
deck is Success was because it has steam
to capitalize on you know it's got the
verification of steam handheld I just
don't see scene like here's the thing
you need a conglomerate of like steam
Playstation Xbox Nintendo something that
actually has some backing to succeed
here just because you can download the
OS is it integrated into this thing
well I mean that I don't know you know I
don't quite there's gonna be questions
about the Asus UI and not to mention you
know for the way they're talking about
it from what I heard it seems like an
easy integration but again I can't
confirm officially I could just go about
what I guess to me it's just like
if you're gonna get something in that
you might as just get steam diet because
it's already built into it I feel like
the majority of the people that's going
to be buying these games they're going
to buy stuff that work more handheld
anyway like a lot of Indie developing
stuff you know certain games that run
well on the steam deck I don't feel like
the issue is the exclusive games to the
platform or games that work on the
platform or something like it's not the
power to me you know there's a reason
switch out sells everything and it runs
like a potato right
if you get the good games everything
else will come afterwards and it's like
you know with VR with the handheld
Market I'm tired of these people be like
we're gonna bring it to you we're gonna
let you play everyone else's stuff oh we
ain't gonna worry about the games we'll
worry about that later but that is that
is the PC ecosystem their mindset is
they want to have everything I know what
you're saying because you're saying life
doesn't make games though yeah they
don't they don't you know you're right
from a game Stamper from a pure Gamers
game point I just wanted to put you in
the mindset of a PC Enthusiast who's
like I I like the games but I want to
play them at the highest Fidelity and
all the bells they played on the PC
well you want it on the Go I mean but
this thing is Zen three this is what
this literally could be powerful PC
itself yeah yeah and you're gonna you're
gonna pay you know half of your mortgage
for it so it's just like look like you
want to go out there and it means that
much to you we got a product whatever
the hell's the thing they just said it's
called Ally and then you know if we we
got a product for you if you want to you
know play on the go in general it's
called Uh the PlayStation uh the
whatever the scene
and then we got you know we got we got
the switch for it you want to play uh
Nintendo's first party but guess what
all of these don't have in common what
Nintendo's library of exclusive game
only for that platform that's out
selling all these com all these combined
times eight they're not touching those
numbers
and at the end of the day until you get
those games it's going to force people
to go somewhere you know what's funny we
go on the this platform and I see people
scream from the top of the day longs on
Twitter all day exclusives bring people
to the platforms but for some reason the
handheld Market that don't count well we
already know that exclusives uh don't
matter so isn't it
okay it's just like look like if you
want people to go to these platforms you
need platform exclusives to get people
to go to these why is people spend an
extra 200 to make their game run a
little bit better to 300 when they could
just buy a steam deck that that already
functions and has a close relationship
with steam the people that actually buy
the games from and we gotta talk about
that in general there's a lot of steam
Fanboys probably way more than there are
Xbox and Playstation Fanboys and good
luck getting any of them to buy
something that's not steam Affiliated on
the PC market I mean but the PC is open
source you can put whatever you want
whatever so you can have this deal
there's no I get that but when we see it
right now there's uh the epic game store
there's Windows
all that exists on PC and the steam
Fanboys would rather go out and buy the
game on Steam then download another
platform to play anywhere they could do
the same thing they could literally have
yeah there's nothing but I understand
your point on the mindset
um I do want to get King on Wednesday
thank you as far as um the Ally man you
know um this machine oh
yeah Windows 11 oh Windows 11 because
steam doesn't have so it's marketed with
Xbox eight time you saw the marketing on
this one right
Game Pass yeah
Microsoft don't need to go out and make
a handheld why they go and get the the
best video game console uh like PC
laptop makers in that in in the area
make it make make a console Hey window
11 you're gonna rock with that hit and
make sure Game Pass is in the Box
one One-Stop shop you wanna put Steam on
it boom whatever it's double the power
of the steam deck so I'm thinking the
thing is going to be like 550 600.
um this is a high price tag for it but
at the same time this thing goes to your
TV yes if you store it if you saw the
whole uh it's just like the switch
it's as powerful well it's way more
powerful to switch as powerful as the
steam deck if not uh two times as
powerful as the steam deck you have the
docking station and you can play your
games now they was playing uh Game Pass
right off the rip so for all you capping
Xbox dudes oh I want a handheld I want
to handle well it's gonna be showing up
with Game Pass in the box and you know
what Microsoft said right wherever see
this is the difference between Microsoft
and Sony okay
Sony wants to control the narrative and
wants to control the hardware right they
want to control that aspect of it if
they were making the ecosystem broader
and open as far as they say like we want
to be one-on-one with the PC they really
don't
they're just forced into this corner to
do right Microsoft literally doesn't
care if it's getting past over there let
it go over there oh you you're launching
a console yeah put the game pass in
there what was that little streaming
thing
um
uh that came out and game passes on
there the Logitech gcloud yeah the
Logitech G Microsoft doesn't care
longest game pass you want to have
Gamecast there you can play any game
right that's where the diversity comes
from with them I think this machine is
going to work well for people that has
Game Pass ultimate uh I think it it's
it's
a very Niche handheld it's not going to
sell in large quantities it's going to
be for those enthusiasts yes right right
so I look I played that steam deck I was
on the train yeah
bro yeah it's a difference right it's
not the switch this is some real step up
to the next level play your games
looking fantastic now if this can
outpace that yeah
shout out to akw do you can also attach
she said the EG egpu so like those I
guess Asus has like you know your
external your 40 not whatever you don't
say your 30 80s and all like you could
even attach it on top of what yeah they
got it they showed I saw what you call
it uh did something like that I think it
was um dave2d look I'll jump in um it's
interesting you know this I got my eye
on it I got my eye on it you know as far
as the Ally you know double performance
esteem deck very appealing the price
point is going to be key the price point
is going to be key because my only thing
is
I'll pay for the premium device my issue
is the storage what's the base Storage
level one terabyte you thinking ah
because look if steam deck I'll defer to
Tom on this if steam deck was it 512
yeah and that I mean it was like at that
low and I think valve correctly if I'm
wrong valve is taking a loss on these
Tom do we know on the on the base levels
I'm not entirely sure but I wouldn't be
I wouldn't be surprised if they are
taking a loss yeah yeah so so they got
that then they have the one Terror so if
you're talking double I'm with you King
they may have to come in at six but if
it's the only thing that would bother me
if it's six for like five twelve to you
know like uh gigs you don't say I want
that Sarah but of course you know memory
does cost could be the fast SSD inside I
love that the nvme most definitely the
most likely be inside um I like the
1080p screen 120 hertz is going to be
super smooth here's the key
and I hear where attic is coming from
you know what I mean I just think that
the audiences are not the same you know
what I'm saying I don't think no no no
yes this is the PC audience is different
this is the Enthusiast and the key for
me is going to be the fact that look as
these games get more advanced because
even right now trying to get cyberpunk
and all these other High Fidelity games
on Steam deck yo you got to do all this
configuring you still have to play at
like 40 FPS 30 FPS on some of these
games right and it's about two years old
now so this seems to be the right timing
for the next big jump yeah and if they
catch it whatever the device looks slick
and that's crazy because it just came
out the same thing just yeah and I like
the analog placement kind of Xbox analog
placement like that
um one pair of back buttons no mouse
touch pads but I don't really use the
bounce touch pads on on the deck to be
honest and um they talk about they
support and VR King which is interesting
it's powerful enough to do so yeah they
talk you know it's super quiet because
one thing complain about Steve [__]
when you're playing the Spider-Man
you're playing the hot Fidelity it
starts
then we talk about the Dual fans you
know what I'm saying kind of thing for
the cooling we'll see we'll see it
depends on how they how they launch you
know the price point I think it looks
like a slick device I don't know why
they did April Fool's marketing that was
weird
and they had to tell everybody that this
is not an April Fool yeah they're like
this is real y'all but you did it to
yourself why would you do this
yeah because it because it was called
it's called a lie and everyone thought
yeah
that's hilarious you can't even catch it
alive yeah
we shall see but I I got my eye on it
I'm not gonna hold you but uh yeah
that's what we got man but again I want
to thank legendary Tom Hankerson inside
gaming give me this a little time
playing into our little mystery guest
fun brother we gotta get you back in the
realm the correct way baby one day with
a camera but I respect you your inside
gaming I'm Gonna Keep a Secret keep the
secret but look man love the reporters
you've been happy we're gonna find out
one day Tom is actually Jeff
because he was going over there
but look man brother you're doing a
phenomenal job with the with the inside
sourcing and it's just been you just
been on Fire Man everyone respects you
in the industry so where can the fine
people find you tell us about your
platform tell us about inside game
before you go
yeah you can find me on Twitter just
search some Hendersons that the handles
our underscore Tom underscore Henderson
underscore because yeah I've had six
accounts now
they're coming for you they're somebody
trying to get you yeah
this guy knows too much so you know he
you know how to catch you I know you
real because you're one of the only
people who have correct PlayStation
sourcing that is rare that you all
believe Xbox for some reason I don't
know people are in the building tell him
but nobody gets so this and you've been
on fire so hopefully you have to make
too many accounts continue yeah um and
then the website Insider gaming.com
um that's where all the reporting goes
um do not ask me questions on Twitter
and DMS and stuff because if I know
something I'm gonna report on it on the
website just you know you got to get
them clicks
um uh and and pay for that you know 400
kill I I guess
[Laughter]
like you know your sources and stuff
yeah knowing that you have like a
website and like you're very uh keen on
reporting
at least
this stuff does that do you ever feel
like some people like slowly start to
distance and stuff for you in the
industry do you feel like the people you
generally go to know you're gonna leak
it and they're okay with it
yeah so we've so we've leak and
um I've never approached anyone to ask
for information they've always come to
me knowing that the information is gonna
get leaked wake up they out here talibs
because this is the card I think that's
to cut you this is a great thing this is
one of the things I wanted to ask you
I'm going to have you in the realm
officially but be in that addict open up
the Pandora's Box you know the question
is because I've seen the you know I've
seen the dialogue between you and some
friends of mine and stuff and it seems
to be this ethical thing about whether
you should or shouldn't be doing it but
according to just now what you're saying
is people are coming up to you
to relay information is that correct
yeah yeah of course
um
with ethics I I mean I don't want to
dive in it too much because it it's it's
quite a rabbit hole of
of childhood that's when you come back
in the realm and we'll go yeah we'll go
through all the stitches
but a lot of people that say that I'm
unethical and whatnot are reporting on
all the stuff that I leak that isn't
related to a media ndf that makes sense
yeah so I I understand the ethical point
that somebody is telling me
um that I don't know that you've you've
gone and played redfall and you've got
some information on that
um all the journalists and YouTubers and
signed in India I get the ethical point
on that but because I'm not trained as a
journalist or anything like that I I see
no difference in that compared to an
employee telling me information that is
also under an NDA from them right right
it's only it's only unethical because
they cannot report on it themselves
and they just pass it up hey Tom hit us
with the they just mad cause they ain't
got it
he's he's talking about he's he's saying
the people that that tell him can't
reporter that's true it just sounded
funny I apologize the best thing in the
world he can't they can't say anything
but they give it to somebody who can who
can so yeah in a sense it's a controlled
leak in a way in a way because they want
this out there and they know who to go
to no I well I think a lot of it isn't
like the the corporate Executives want
this out there someone below them was
like yo Tom you want some info
well who knows who knows I don't I don't
know if there's a marketing
that I've said we're going to do a
controlled leak and we'll speak to Tom
or Jeff or or whoever it may be that's
my next question Tom is controlled leaks
exist
um I don't know honestly I I've I've
never had somebody
approach me and say that this is
controlled or whatever
um but I I think there was a leak from a
Capcom game I think where I even said in
the documents like we're gonna do a
controlled leap oh wow wow well yeah I
mean I don't know I don't know if if
there is any anything like controlled
leaks because if somebody contacts me
anonymously anonymously with game
footage documents and whatever then I
don't know the difference between that
and you better watch out though it's all
one of the time rock star someone go pop
in there with their big expensive
lawyers oh I know
[Laughter]
look we'll have you back in a row
brother I really appreciate you always
good to see you last chance you know
appreciate you taking the time out your
day this was a huge story and it was
only right we had you on the platform
for you to explain how it went down and
of course we're gonna get you the the
Royal Treatment that Laura cargan showed
the right way yes please you know that
you know we're gonna do it right
anything you want to say before tom
leaves you had anything yeah I'm pretty
sure you're coming on some uh I've
always you could ask
you're one of the few people in the
industry that I'm like you go around you
know you have info and you're not afraid
to share it and I feel like
I'm gonna be something to say for you I
feel like a lot of people take that
leaking stuff too serious it's like look
like you need to be less bad at Tom for
for relaying the information and more
mad at the people leaking it to him like
it's literally Tom's job in the industry
to cover the stuff and the same people
that came at you are the same people
that will cover it acting like they
don't know it and giving their info
acting like they don't know it so it is
what it is you know I understand there's
a lot of people that go into this uh you
know you your leagues do I'm sure cause
a lot of headache to people in PRS and
stuff but it's just like at the end
that's not your problem but you're
you're doing what you're supposed to and
they need to keep their house on a leash
they need to tighten it up
don't you do that you get what I'm
saying like you know when it comes to
and I will say like Insider games like
one of the few Place uh people on
Twitter that I have bailed because I
know whatever shows up it's gonna be lit
but I definitely appreciate you coming
on we got to get you on a full time not
really I'm not really about to face cam
like they are man I I take you just
growing his eyebrows back leave him
alone after the king followers for Louis
Tomlinson before I I love I love I love
going back and forth with Tom on Twitter
Tom it's funny that he shows up you know
almost every week he's you know witty
and I share your your uh views on
somebody giving you information
you're not nobody's hard drive so you
don't need to store anything let that go
so as soon as they tell you listen I got
a website and if you don't own
allegiance to anyone either well he owes
allegiance to the dudes and I'm pretty
sure when they when they hit him with
the information no I'm not talking about
them I'll talk about the companies oh
the hell with them
um and he's and they say he probably
asked him yo can I say anything
because I get stuff and they'll be like
you don't say anything
so then why the hell you tell me
don't tell me if I can't tell nobody
and I get sick and tired of it so half
the time I don't even pay my DMs anymore
but um if if they say yo let this go do
your thing
it's not on you it's not your problem so
it is what it is but
I'm glad that you came on I'm glad that
I'm going to get a a console out of this
um
fantastic though but um yo I can't wait
for you to come on we're gonna do a live
unboxing we're gonna have a good time
anyway
that's the need to come on Tom when they
announce that
would be good when it gets a dollar as
hell that would be a good time
yes let's do it after the Showcase all
right brother Tom enjoy your day happy
Easter thank you so much brother have a
good one all right yes guys cheers no
doubt attic you want to get this Super
Chat sir is a lot of them it's just
going to take me a second I'll be back
while you do it because I gotta hit the
bathroom too so you go
all right guys you got to work with me
all right so this is this is the the
game plan when I'm reading these
uh don't expect me to pronounce your
stuff right all right don't expect right
now don't expect it to don't expect it
to be sounded right
that's all that's all let's let's get on
with this man let's get on with it so we
had a five dollar super chop from uh
Master pontus first time making a live
can't stay long but happy Easter Lords
much love and looking forward to hearing
this tomorrow by the way Mario movie was
fired I only got the Mario movie okay I
didn't get the rest so I hope I hope
that's what you said I had to just
assume you said fire all right then we
got uh we got a member chat from Hardy
Chennai put the logos in the chat you
guys he said well well well Jim Ryan
expects ponies to die to dessert uh
Playstation and droves of all in your
court ponies prove him right leave PS
call him a liar and stay on Playstation
decisions decisions decisions argue
being really uh really spicy today
really spicy let me make these a little
bigger I'm getting a little bit old
these days man getting a little bit old
these days all right so we gotta find
out super trap from harvino Inga you
know I definitely butchered that my
apologies
a week later still laughing about how
[__] said my name well you can laugh
harder about how I said your name
because I'm sure it was wrong
uh love from Ireland Iceland to the
Lords I appreciate all the love man we
got people that's everywhere everywhere
Iceland five dollars for five dollars
from free R Kelly you Konami Capcom
Square Enix are all going to Sony
King it's a rat it's over Final Fantasy
never coming to Xbox just burn your lame
box now
oh you back on ASAP good stay there so
so you done okay that's all right we got
another two dollar shot from Harvey
Shiny Happy Easter to the IOP famine
this Lord's Day what's up
that's my guy
got a 20 shoe trap from sin Vendetta
I've seen Super Mario Brothers twice
since Wednesday and it's fantastic yeah
so many good references to every era of
Mario and you'll need multiple watches
to catch them catch them all yeah I
don't think that you can even catch them
on multiple watches like you guys have
to really sit there for five seconds
yeah it's it's I think that's gonna be
one of those you have to have it you
have to have like the Blu-Ray so you
could literally just rewind that section
over and over again yeah uh all seeing
it seeing it a third time very soon
fantastic start
we got a member trap from Gerald Mack 20
months he's been a member he's uh he's
silver Jim Wright could lie as much as
he wants to uh to his own numbers we'll
prove he's a fraud all held the IOP to
the Lords appreciate that man we gotta
follow the super trap from drawn TJ if
Chris Farley was still alive he could
easily replace Jim Ryan and run Sony
better yo he's still okay wow got to
show a Supertramp From Roberts kellets
so Sony selling remakes of our phones
question mark I have no clue what's
going on there
is remake of your cell phone
because we gotta find out we got five
thousand percent from Hollywood rules
happy Easter and happy Lord's Day
Brothers
crying Jim is still a Bad episode of
Better Call Saul thank you and keep
being the best podcast on YouTube
absolutely appreciate that man do you
know from t
a uh
thx138 another PSP Go Out In Flames got
a two dollar subscribe from Robert
Kellis when a stream deck is only a
hundred and fifty dollars more
one one three eight switch OLED 3 uh 49
steam Tech four uh 3.99 Sony not uh not
cheaper no he agrees with you King yeah
it's just it won't be
we gotta find a description from Robert
Kellis King saying Sony pulled a Sega
question mark should debate on if they
gonna pimp ratchet like they did the
Blue Boy Sonic guys okay I don't think
so um I think those ratchet games they
they hold those in weird high regard
very very rare high regard we got to
find out super trap from Max arthy uh
Playstation uh Remote Play handheld
feels like Sony just followed a trend
never which never works well for them if
you look at Vita TV and PS1 classic
similar flop question mark yes sir we
gotta be right we got a five dollar
super trap from Hollywood rolls got my
Logitech G to use them in the office at
work excellent Game Pass machine and I'm
not a handheld dude but helps cut into
the crazy backlog I have that's what's
up we gotta find out uh two dollar super
trap from uh Dawn to talku if the alley
had native uh Xbox game passes it's
better than the deck yeah it does have
native um XBox game pass I mean the
native app yeah
we got a we got a member chap from slash
Gordon it's been there for 11 months
dashboard oh stash is it a stash
for 11 months he's he's right there at
that year anyone think the series s was
designed to eventually be shrunk into a
handheld in a few years down the line
seems like a good long-term play if
possible that's a good point yeah that's
a good point I don't know if it's
possible but if it is yeah a little man
yeah let's let's do that let somebody
find out
Asus is more appealing to me than the
steam deck runs windows so access to all
PC games and plays play night exist as
an interface so uh so does you uh use
you I don't know zip Davis uh two dollar
Super Chat from zip Davis hello Loris
happy Easter have a great week
absolutely then another Super Chat zip
days two dollars who needs a mid-gen
refresh when you can play bong did you
play it on turbo Express
are we good
uh yes that is awesome I appreciate it I
appreciate you let's get to it so I they
there might be some more I just don't I
don't see the chat okay I think zip
Davis was the last dude yeah so if you
see anyone if anybody missed let's let
us know who needs a mid-gen refresh when
you can yeah play ball yeah we just got
that we just got that all right let's
get to it um Sony in the news again
um so it looks like Microsoft and Sony
have responded to the cma's revised
findings I gotta get some stuff to put
on my wall they could they saying this
this only fasting a couple with too many
times
so so so you you hold up you mean to
tell me that what signifies only fans is
a white wall is that what you guys are
telling uh what tell me is when you had
that camera too low and we seeing things
we don't need to be seeing you spread
out within like this like that was what
it was only fast time
I wasn't feeling the legs the leg action
you see him slide his pillow into place
anyway let's get to it so look um
Microsoft and Sony have responded to the
cmh's revised findings that Microsoft's
purchase of Activision Blizzard will not
harm competition in the console space so
it looks like uh Sony is upset with the
CMA while Microsoft welcomes CMAs you
turn on the Activision deal so basically
the latest amount of the Publishers are
sponsors out there to the addendum the
Microsoft position is Microsoft has been
clear since the announcement of the
merger it has no intention to withhold
or degrade access to Call of Duty or any
other activation content on Playstation
Microsoft wrote Such a strategy would be
in direct contrast to the interests of
gamers in the UK and around the world
rather than limit choice of access
Microsoft intends to use the merge to
bring more games to more peoples on more
platforms and devices meanwhile Sony on
the reverse or cma's reverse position
now this is surprising unprecedented and
irrational
um Sony respectively submits that the
addendum does not justify the cma's
u-turn on the console series of harm and
then um they basically went on to say
actually Jim Ryan has some really strong
comments this week it kind of went viral
um so uh Sony interactive president and
CEO Jim Ryan in response to the UK
regular CMA
um addendum he said that PlayStation
would never recover if Microsoft were
typically were to release a degraded
membership
at least a degraded version of Call of
Duty on Playstation if it's acquisition
of Activision Blizzard were to be
approved Ryan also said a degraded
version of Call of Duty on Playstation
with seriously damaged our reputation
our Gamers would desert our platform in
drones and network effects would
exacerbate the problem our business
would never recover on a degraded
version of play so this is the one that
really set the internet on fire so you
know the story continues it's a skit
addict man you know what do you feel on
Jim Ryan snorts and looks like the CMA
has reversed position and it looks like
they are agreeing that at the Call of
Duty situation the the exact Microsoft
Is providing would not harm competition
so they're reversing their initial
thought process after this next phase of
the investigation
uh first stuff do you think uh we should
bring anyone else you think 30 of us
just rocked we could rock this is gonna
be a short show today it's gonna be a
show yeah so yeah I think when it comes
down to it and it's just like look
I get it you know when it comes down to
Call of Duty is a big seller for them
and that makes them generates with them
a lot of money and I do think there are
some remnants of Truth in their words
because they're scared that what's going
to end up happening throughout the years
because the Game Pass they're start
gonna they're gonna slowly lose that
massive Call of Duty casual place
leaving PlayStation coming to Xbox
because if they don't have to pay for
anything it's hard to tell uh you know
the amount of stuff they can do with the
Call of Duty Brian just because they put
Call of Duty doesn't mean they can do
little things on top of just okay we're
gonna give you Call of Duty every year
but what we didn't say is
we're gonna give you Call of Duty here
going out now let's and then then you
you you find out a couple years down the
line they remake all the the Black Ops
put them in the collection and they
don't get that there's a lot of
semantics to this that I could
understand where Sony's coming from
where it's like look we don't know the
future if we lose Call of Duty and it
could literally Domino affect them
losing a huge Market a huge uh part part
of the market but
that's but when they do stuff like score
Enix we're pretty much locking an entire
developer down by making timed
exclusives that's where you lose me when
you want sympathy right I don't care
about your sympathy Sony if you if you
were really about that life if they came
out there they were just on it's like
look we need this Call of Duty stuff but
to me it's just acting like they aren't
though they're acting like they're the
victim they're acting like they're the
people doing everything wrong and what
they act like they don't throw stones
you through you throw Boulders and
you're trying to act like people can't
do anything about it you know they go
they want to ride all this year and
they'll call you by Bethesda that's fine
you know that's a problem but it's the
future it's not right now we're good and
then they say Activision oh what what
what what
Call of Duty like see here's the thing
they make so much money off Call of Duty
they're scared they're gonna lose that
and not to mention 10 years down the
line Microsoft pulls up on them after
that that senior deal was up it's okay
how much you want Call of Duty to stay
on your platform uh we want 50 50. we
want we want some of your money we ain't
doing this 30 70 anymore we want more of
your money and it's just I think I do
think that PlayStation has the
the potential of what could happen on
their side and they should be no I don't
think anyone's ever said they shouldn't
fight for their company
for what's going on but to me the issue
is how they're doing it they're trying
to throw rocks and act like they ain't
throwing rocks it's like that that that
Meme where you're you're throwing
something and then it looks back and he
looks back and he's on the ground like
he's he's like look my PlayStation you
are doing these practices that's not
worse practices degrading and the
PlayStation yeah they've been degraded
yeah man up both the the grade that you
does
and you're gonna have to deal with that
you have to deal with that L you thought
you could poke the the Big Bear for
years and then when he when he wakes up
then he starts buying things out like
they ain't know tomorrow now he's like
no don't do that like well you just got
to deal with it you did this to yourself
you went out there instead of investing
into a multiplayer infrastructure to get
that multiplayer infrastructure out
there you felt comfortable with with
what third party stuff could do
Microsoft popped and there's like that's
ours that ain't yours anymore now
they're sitting here looking at this
golden egg and they're like what's gonna
happen if they buy this right and 10
years down the line and they decide they
don't want these terms anymore they just
want to pull let's say right now Call of
Duty's in a good uh like you know kind
of an okay spot but the 10 years down
the line they make a couple games that
put it way up like back where it used to
be used to be and then Xbox comes back
to the negotiating tables like you can't
can't negotiate with us we don't want to
it on your platform anymore and it's I
don't know if it's in their best
interest to do that because they can't
be yeah but we don't but right now the
Microsoft now who says Game Pass doesn't
floors then and then they're looking at
a a they're looking at it like okay we
got about 100 okay we're talking like 10
years from now 100 150 million users in
Game Pass which you know we don't know
if it's gonna go that far but that's the
thing they're not arguing on the
semantics of what happens now they're
arguing on semantics what happens five
ten years down the line right they know
that Call of Duty is the biggest
Behemoth in gaming and they're like we
cannot risk them having those type of
negotiating Tools 10 years down the line
it's just that's what it comes down to
and say I don't mind them doing what
they're doing I think what happened is
they made a couple of statements and
they realized how much they were shaking
up the industry doing this so they're
like let's just make ourselves look look
ignorant let's make ourselves look weak
let's make ourselves look like we ain't
done nothing in the industry that's
anti-consumer then let's make it it's
look like we ain't Nothing by blocking
games going to Game Pass blocking games
going to Xbox and let's just act like
none of that happens right and let's say
that they're the bad guys and tires
that's my biggest issue no I understand
that I mean it's clear they don't care
about any public perception of weakness
of how they look or whatever like that
so it's clear the the mission is you
know that they're not going to sign the
deal or gonna try to block the deal at
all at all costs right I hear on that
and I hear you on the uh you know I
guess 10 years down the future you know
thought process of what could yeah I
think that's the biggest thing is
they're like look we can we can say
what's happening now because it's
happening right in front of us the next
year or two we kind of know where the
landscape is going to go
especially things going to more
Subscription Service more live streaming
service like Sony doesn't know where
they're going to be in 10 years from now
and if they get if Microsoft gets to a
point yeah Microsoft gets to a point
where they don't realistically need the
place let's say called let's say that
the the Call of Duty thing works the way
Xbox think it's going to work and they
start draining mad people from
PlayStation and then it gets to the
point where six seven years down the
right Xbox is way has way more market
share because they've had a lot more of
the marketers for Call of Duty and then
it just gets to the point where they're
like look we don't even need ourselves
anymore that's where I mean just if
you're a Microsoft from a business
standpoint do you walk away for free
money just for it existing on a base
that's larger than yours you don't
really work with it don't make sense and
to be honest for The Regulators this is
a key point to help them get the deal to
tell The Regulators hey we're letting
them have it they don't want to sign the
deal for whatever reason but we telling
them you're gonna have it power 30 you
will have it on your platform so I think
business-wise and then let's be honest
from a game let's just look at as a game
standpoint from a game standpoint
for cross play and all the stuff like
from an engagement from a user-based
population or online population you want
PlayStation there so that you can have
that huge power-based engagement micro
transactions keep it keep the love going
and hey you just getting the money thing
is sodi's just giving you money for it
existing I mean so you know before it
existing on PlayStation and the gaming
industry it moves mad fast 10 years yeah
they literally might just be
subscription Services fighting each
other there might not be any games
that's being sold independently
if you're in that kind of scenario
because that's where I think we're going
we're eventually going to get to a point
where you plug something in here your
hard drive stop acting like no one else
has said that I understand when I said
there's no PlayStation 6 everybody look
at me like I'm crazy you plug something
into a into a TV or something and then
what's happening with that you plug
something into a TV and it just loads
the Xbox store with all the Xbox stuff
in it and you know the Ubisoft launcher
that's right I feel we're going because
if you have that kind of scenario when
everything is subscription based where
it does look like it's going that would
not make sense to put your biggest thing
on the enemy's Subscription Service when
you're trying to buff yours up you know
I I get that I mean I tell you is we
don't know what the the industry is
going to look like it's starting to
sound just like him
you know 10 years we we don't know
what's gonna happen and we also don't
know the viability of Call of Duty in
Texas that that's I think that's the
story of what the mystery of what could
happen is what scare is called oh is
what scares PlayStation they're going to
and they realize down the road it could
either go up or down but they know the
money they're bringing in now is
significant enough to fight for
absolutely absolutely Lord King your
thoughts on this situation looks like
the CMA has reversed course does not
feel that um Call of Duty on Xbox with
harm competition in the console space
and Jim Ryan's quotes you know said that
they wouldn't be able to recover just
not even just for having it but on a
degraded version of Call of Duty if
there was a degraded version of Call of
Duty if Microsoft the greater Call of
Duty or Playstation their business would
never recover people would flock to Xbox
two things
first thing somebody paid off the wrong
dude that's me what you mean you greased
the wrong Palms because you thought it
was gonna go in your favor and then they
they got the sheet they was like yeah
nah it's cool
you was like yo wait a second wait a
second what happened to that five G's
that I slid you B like I thought we was
on the same page no you picked Javier
you ain't paying me
I'm happier
it's against the deal but Javier don't
gotta vote you you talk to the wrong NDA
dude oh
talk to the right people okay yeah you
know Microsoft Microsoft went and spent
millions of dollars out there
hey hey your infrastructure is messed up
here fix that
that yo like like that Microsoft went in
the club saw the girl that you messing
with and brought a Birkin bag and some
Redbox
step step your joint up because you're
looking kind of nasty hanging out with
your boy not to mention King let's
theoretically say that Xbox finds that
good middle ground and no latency of
x-cloud and now they got Call of Duty
every year to put in that sucker and I
think that's what they're scared of that
that's what they grow up because you can
you continue by snitching you could
theoretically start an entire company
off just Call of Duty like that's how
big that Behemoth is it can do anything
it wants you could do anything in this
industry knowing that you have Call of
Duty on your back to do anything with it
okay so because I was completely quiet
you notice I was completely okay
talk you're talking oh [__] yes okay
you said well
time on both of y'all
honestly we got to the point right now
[Music]
you know stop crying brother stop crying
they don't want to they don't want to
give Microsoft the money because they
know Microsoft is going to take that
money and reinvest into their ecosystem
all the money that that they're giving
Activision Blizzard that money is going
to be going to Microsoft it's really not
about it's funding your enemy like yeah
I'm getting something from you and we're
making tons of money but that money
wasn't going to Microsoft before facts
so Microsoft could die out without this
funnel of money
so you know the checks that you're
sending to Activision Blizzard those
checks will be going to Microsoft now
Activision Blizzard
imagine the the Marcus start sliding and
you're paying them knowing that you're
paying your own funeral that's what I'm
talking about it's you're paying you're
fueling your own demise
literally it's painting you when you
hand over the money you know he's
getting stronger like so let's say you
send them a check for three billion
right he take that 3 billion and go buy
another another developer he did say he
sorry yeah
but he's like yo it's taco seasoning
season is still going and then you send
him another check for another three
billion he bought another developer like
yo stop sending the money right so
you're you're caught in between a rock
and a hard place you want Call of Duty
so bad but you don't want to funnel
Microsoft Microsoft is positioning in
itself to destroy you and and they tell
you you can have everything when
somebody tells you don't worry about it
you got that you already know you got
beef with somebody in the street and
they were like nah B you got that you
good oh no you were good you know they
got something in up their sleeves they
ain't even worried about it that's not
at all so go ahead baby go ahead play
boy that's on you dude
Playboy Playboy Playboy
Playboy you can have that Call of Duty
Playboy
yes
because you know Jim is out there nah
man that's that's inconceivable this is
reprehensible we will never recover so
whoever not to mention that they
probably gave like what's 10 years in
the gaming industry it's like it's
probably gonna take them 10 years to
build the infrastructure they want built
to do what they want with Call of Duty
like no I don't think so I think they
already have a plan that's going to
implement very quickly right they see
Microsoft already have they got like an
order orders what is the order 66 but
they just click and it just switches
over the Call of Duty black yeah but
when you when you see them like what
they did with Bethesda and you saw all
the Dooms and all the fallouts and all
that stuff just go inside Game Pass
when when that happens and and that's an
actual thing because it will be a
reality
then the value of your brand your your
service is diminished right and then
you're gonna say well Microsoft is not
going to degrade when somebody says and
this is my last point on this when
somebody tells you
don't do that playful yo what if what if
they put oil in your tank your car I
don't trust that dude what if you put
oil in anything that means you the dude
that put oil when people take you
snitching on yourself you got a
self-fulfilling prophecy you're
projecting what you do or that
individual because you think that
individual is like you
Microsoft is like why would we degrade a
product that is our brand
to get to your platform we want to put
the best to so your customers can
actually have a good time why would we
put out our name behind crap
Sony and and let's let's keep it a buck
A lot of these games that they gave help
to developers a lot of those games came
to Microsoft broken
um
look back at that track record let's
let's look in in those handshake deals
in the background maybe you could drop a
couple of frames
oh this will be doing yeah yeah don't
optimize they join over there Playboy uh
yeah just just leave they join the
little uh yeah don't finish that code
right there
ugly they're projecting practices that
they used to do okay because
that's yo really you've never heard
nobody give a while out scenario like
that in business it's not I won't sell a
lesser version of my car just because
like let's say Tesla right yeah and they
they send a Tesla cars to China I'm not
going to send a lesser version of Tesla
in China it represents the brand right
right so I'm gonna send the same best
Tesla that I have here that I'm gonna
send over in China the same thing I'm
not going to give you an inferior
version of Call of Duty because it
diminishes my brand I wanted to sell on
your platform because I want you to pay
me to funnel the war against you okay
but but what if what if they let's say
it's what you said it is right right so
what if it's like okay we know we gonna
lose this deal so we need these
assurances that you ain't gonna do these
practices okay I'm not gonna do nothing
is there even any concessions right now
well we're not at that point but we
could get there right so may what if
what if the kick it
low-key feel like this might go through
no concessions because it's look like
Microsoft has has it like they haven't
been they're like look we we taking this
to the we taking this to the courtrooms
if we have to like if you won't play
ball we won't play ball and it's looking
like it's got to that point where it
might get approved by concessions
because they didn't accept the
concessions hilarious it's a possibility
we don't we definitely don't know but um
what I was saying is what if all of this
is to well let's say I'm going to give
Kingdom let's say everything King said
is true right Sony's been doing this
like he says right yeah they do they do
the first okay so now it's like okay we
need you in writing that you gonna give
us full parity no degradation you know
and we want all these these things kind
of lined up before we even consider it
or the other option which is I don't
care what you do I've never signing that
deal that's Duty right so Jim could be
according to Lulu shout out to Lulu
she's outside she claims that Jim says I
will whatever I have to do to block this
deal I will say whatever I got to do I
will do so right so yeah she outside but
um so what if that's the play and they
like yo we ain't signing nothing and we
gonna take it to whatever
about that listen I already know Jim
is Never Gonna sign
never he already made a fool of himself
there's no there's no way for you to
walk this back this you came out and
said first of all my people are not
enough second of all if this happens we
will never recover third of all this is
the detriment to the industry it's going
to destroy all you cannot walk back any
of those comments so you got you've
doubled down so hard that you gotta
stand You Got a Sinking hand you're
playing blackjack or or or or whatever
or whatever I don't care Blackjack and
you got a sink in hand and you still in
it because you got no choice you gotta
ride this one out so I feel him
but at the same time you had a you could
have had a peaceful resolution to all of
this and got past this but you know it's
funny it seemed like he was I feel like
him trying a strong arm Microsoft into
making a deal with Call of Duty and then
I feel like there's a point where that's
what his objective was you know we we
know we can't stop this deal but what
I'm gonna do is I'm gonna do what I can
I'm a poke host to the defense to get
good concessions and just make it as
difficult as possible I feel like it got
to a point where that wasn't the goal
anymore like yo I think I could stop
this I don't think we even have to do
this right and then it seemed like
somewhere between there and here
Microsoft started winning the arguments
you know I mean it's clear that they are
with the CMA and now Sony's at the point
where they're like do we look
do we look weaker than we actually even
weaker and come out there and say yo
okay I know we we agreed on concessions
and I know I said no can we get those
concessions now I I think at this point
PlayStation is just going to go down
with the [__] regardless if it's passed
or not I think at this point they're
like we already passed the concessions
part at this point either we win and you
don't get this merger or acquisition or
we win and it gets blocked and I think
those are the only two outcomes at this
point yeah we got to see and then like I
said the cma's reversal and now saying
that you know Call of Duty on Xbox does
not harm competition you know flies in
the face of what remember what what Jim
Ryan and and was promoting to the CMA
how it would right and the angel
argument has always been you know let's
be honest the elephant in a room which
nullifies everything is Nintendo you
know the fact that Nintendo exists and
is on Pace to be the third maybe even
best console ever sold ever and they
have not had Call of Duty on their
platform you know literally flies in the
face of the argument now the question
becomes that's when let's be honest the
goal post was moved by Sony instead as
well that's not a high-end console
Market yeah you know this is a low end
but they said that was a fitness device
of a low-end console but like Brazil and
it seems like Japan you know they don't
buy that because they're saying that
look again Nintendo exists this game is
not that's your version now the thing
that's interesting to me is what um they
had a uh what you call it I believe uh
I think it's a lawyer or um excuse me no
no associate professor he had an
interesting response as far as clogging
because this is the part that I thought
Microsoft might lose the argument which
is on cloud gaming and how dominant they
are but he argues in this actual
addendum they put this into the addendum
so CMA is really signing with Microsoft
on a lot of things including Cloud which
he's saying cloud gaming is not a
distinct Market he he said he instead
refers to four types of gaming service
that rely on arms Cloud streaming cloud
gaming as a feature as seen on Game Pass
cloud gaming as a compliment which you
see in the Jeep and Nvidia GeForce com
Glade cloud gaming as an input you you
videos and uh game stream and cloud
gaming as a platform which is uh Amazon
Luna he said in his conclusion he wrote
consumers willingness to pay for
Standalone cloud gaming Services
apparently is low and this is probably
the strongest indication that cloud
gaming should not be considered a
distinct Market this is a huge win for
Microsoft yeah because they are it might
have been the
last thing they needed to push it over
there yes no one's talking about it like
this because I feel like that was the
key yes component that Sony could have
used to fight to me that was the
argument they should have went but not a
CMA don't even feel that part because
they're like probably no one even fought
it really that hard but the it the fact
that they're saying they don't consider
it a distinct market and Microsoft has
Azure in that backbone and they're
growing it's hugely beneficial for
Microsoft in this space so now we get
back to where we are now look we just
got to be real you know you know the me
when you go out there and say the mere
as far as sodium the mere degradation of
this product yep means we can't exist in
the video game Space a product that you
don't own in control yep just that it's
degraded we like it gotta be honest it
does scream desperation you know um you
know shout out I think Jaffe had the
quote of the year like Jaffe was like
shout out to John for you said your
whole business is you mean to tell me
this is his response to Jim Ryan your
whole business is built around one game
that you have zero control over F I've
had I've heard of not putting all your
eggs in one basket but Jim Ryan seems to
be saying that not only he did that but
you don't even own the effing basket I
get it he'll say whatever he needs to
but damn
so yeah that's where we at you know I
think that's where we at and um I think
you know the CMA kind of sees through it
now I think the FTC is the final piece
and um it's gonna be like what addicts
they're gonna fold like a dick you see
the goal they're gonna fold it's either
going to be they fight
they need to go full pre beforehand with
the concessions or they fight and then
if they do fight we know Microsoft's
willing to take it there and and approve
it regardless I mean go through it
regardless so let me ask you guys a
question then um you know first off
shout out to we have
730 people in the chat you know hit that
like button we got 223 likes and we got
700 you in there man I can literally
make an army with you guys like explain
to everybody hit the like button right
hit the like button hit the like who are
we saving today
PlayStation Fanboys today that's what we
say the long arm koala
why why can't we save the short arm for
a while thank you short on koalas they
can't fight that's your friends
hit the like button yeah especially
y'all here on Easter salute Saloon so
yeah I mean that that's pretty much what
I got short hair bunny rabbit we saving
the short hair
I believe I talked about that like yeah
but yeah we'll wait for the uh final
piece with the FTC but uh yeah things
look like it's really going in
Microsoft's Direction and we just got to
see how long how much longer we have
with this Super Chat sir the next topic
okay
I gotta bring up the things
I said it's just a matter of time before
the hammer crushes them yeah you're just
gonna start hearing that uh It's The
Final Countdown song now all I hear is
how can I live without
[Laughter]
mm-hmm
[Music]
got a two dollar super trap from Sony
I ain't even butchering that man you
just your name is Sony today I'm sorry
what happens to Microsoft if Sony never
signs
what happens to Microsoft what happens
to Sony it's not Microsoft Microsoft
just keeps selling
uh I I guess maybe he's under the
impression that Microsoft like they
can't get it unless Microsoft signs it I
don't know they don't they don't need
them if they don't sign they don't get
it and if you don't get it you already
know you die so you commit you can do
whatever you want every character is so
full you like don't do that you better
take this deal Playboy
we gotta find a super trap from Robert
kellett yeah so they acting like they
don't do the exact thing with cholesto
the latest Resident Evil Hogwarts and
more maybe King was on with uh with
money with uh parody
they've been doing that they're putting
little spies and tearing up stuff in the
industry well we know we know from an
exclusive content standpoint I mean even
Hogwarts Legacy had exclusive
PlayStation quests and stuff like that
I'm talking about them over there making
games run worse
we got a 10 scripture from Max arthi
mm-hmm that's your name today having
your entire business revolve around one
single product produced by a third party
is terrible business tracks sounds like
a gym crying writing problem to me I
don't think it's that the world revolves
around Call of Duty I think their
financials revolve around Call of Duty
they bring so much money in and having
the marketing deal they would fight this
even if they kept the game indefinitely
but they would find it just for the
marketing deal yeah like the marketing
deal is just as big as the game in a lot
of ways uh we got a 10 subject from
gamer by choice is right I think Sony
hold up let's moment of silence is right
over here right
I think Sony is scared of 10 years in
the future the reason Microsoft uh
leaving Call of Duty on PlayStations
because their play their play they have
players now what about 10 years I think
Sony is scared of foreclosure I use the
glitches two dollar super trap from uh
TX uh
thx1138 with AB day uh the ABK deal Sony
you're not the father of God yo five
dollars from black Ronin it's not
Microsoft's concerned worry about Sony
it's there's concern to worry about this
if somebody's user base can be can
benefit Microsoft Sony can die all I
care yeah okay all right find out
subtract from Max if you flip the script
Sony is the type to be telling folks
they need to buy The Aviator to survive
I don't think you see Phil crying this
much about it no
five dollar super shot from black Rodman
Sony will be mad if XBox becomes lead
platform for college since it's it would
scale better on PC also then this
requires extra work for Sony devs so
what Sony remembers is when uh 360 was
the lead platform for Call of Duty the
table's turned
yeah 360 days were crazy and it's coming
back you're funny okay let me find
you're gonna feel the script Sony will
get this one you're ridiculous okay we
got to send out from Max what's up Max I
know uh you have a last name but today
you don't Sony lion to Regulators about
not being able to survive but this still
goes through which we'll all know this
isn't true Telltale style regulator not
The Telltale Regulators remember that
remember when you played them games
remember that when you made a bad
decision yeah that's funny good luck Max
that was actually hilarious
then we got a uh
a a members chap from Suicide Kings I've
been a member for 29 months
that's a long time I want to ask Carl
being our Sony man wow does he think the
ABK deal is good for gaming overall by
the way happy Easter uh Sony man talks
yeah hilarious
um yes I I think that one because people
forget that here's the thing people keep
using this narrative that I'm seeing
that Microsoft just went in there and
they just running around buying stuff
which I'm not gonna say they ain't doing
with other stuff but in this particular
case people forget this was a fire sale
Activision Blizzard King was up out of
here right they were going through all
that turmoil and then Robert is out here
putting it y'all we out for sale cotec
and Microsoft swooped in so this is
being an opportunist this I think people
losing sight of the overall how this
deal came about the Microsoft didn't
even ask yeah like Dave
that's what this is this isn't like they
came in yo I'm who's who's out for sale
I'm ready
these dudes was going out of here I
think the biggest thing that I would say
this is good for gaming is because if
you look at like Activision as a whole
the past like five ten years the
majority of their company always makes
Call of Duty I feel like there's more
things that could be done than just
college and I'm not saying they're gonna
stop Call of Duty I don't think that's
going to happen but what I will say is
there is quite a bit of other potential
stuff that can go on with that company
as a whole and I feel like they're not
doing it because the amasses amount of
money they can make off Call of Duty I
think they're still going to make that
money they're still going to bring out
those games but I think with Microsoft
they're going to let people slip and
swap like now you know when it comes to
certain developers you know we might go
ahead and double down on another studio
and let this studio make something else
we're not gonna We're Not Gonna tether
the Call of Duty and keep in mind right
now it's just Activision when when
Microsoft buys them they it's going to
be one of those things where certain
devs instead of losing that Talent
they're gonna be like look we have these
other 30 plus Studios that you can go
work for and and get that you know
straight that that creative muscle you
don't have to be just stuck on Call of
Duty what I was going to say just real
quickly because he asked me this
question um yeah just Call of Duty I
really care about but the fact that our
game pass is huge when people play helps
Microsoft on that but we got the mobile
aspect which no one's talking about
which is going to be huge for them I'm
looking at the old IPS that they can use
I'm looking at the older games that
could come in the back compat and the
more important thing to me is the fact
that the conditions at Activision
business was really bad and people are
losing sight of that so there's no one
ever to force change in that building
that to me because all eyes will be on
Microsoft once they acquire so that's
how I look at it overall continue
all right then we got a couple uh we got
a member chat let me make sure yeah we
got a member from Suicide Kings again oh
no that he just asked us that find out
super chat from Harvey shiny Sony
doesn't need to sign a Dell PS already
have called through 2024. everything
after that is up to Sony Xbox will be at
the table if they want to do I don't
know argue I kind of feel like if they
keep pushing this and Microsoft does get
this with no concessions I don't think
Microsoft's gonna be here's there's
going to be a deal of concessions
regardless what happens on both adjacent
the question is is how much on the left
is going to get before Sony realizes
they're not going to win this and who
knows by the time they go to the table
with Microsoft Microsoft be like yeah
we're going to give you what we offered
you last time minus this this and this
yeah who knows what the the terms are
going to be the longer this goes but
we'll see
are we good
yeah all right let's get into it
um Joseph stay in y'all Joseph stay in
the legend head of creative or Halo
infinite and cinematic director of the
first three Halo games is leaving
Microsoft just according to IGN in the
article they go on to say Microsoft goes
on to say we're grateful for Joseph's
contributions to the Halo franchise and
Xbox as a whole the statement um we wish
you all the best in his new adventure uh
Staton himself took to Twitter saying um
hey folks I am indeed leaving Microsoft
I have more info to share soon but for
now I'd just like to thank all my Xbox
colleagues for all their understanding
support as I embark on a new adventure
so Stayton has been known then for the
uh one being the one behind the Halo
franchise cinematic director on Halo
Combat evolve Halo 2 Halo 3 and served
as the lead writer on Destiny while with
Bungie so the resume is immense he
eventually left as Mark Bungie from
Microsoft then and served as a senior
creative director initially avoiding
343's Halo to focus on shaping franchise
strategy for Microsoft Studio uh titles
after that he returned um for Halo
infinite to help as a consultant and
then he rejoined Xbox publishing earlier
this year so that he's been this is kind
of a lifer you know he's been there
around through it he's been through it
he's been he's been up down around and
so on and so forth and it's now leaving
so thoughts on the legendary
let me get these two members real quick
because they didn't show up later yeah
yeah I got a got a 30 month member from
Mike asked Junior skill Junior happy
Easter and UFC delivered then we got a
32 months uh from Big Mad Mo yeah happy
Easter shout out to the Lords of the
realm all right what's up Salute brother
I mean when it comes to like Joseph's
Dayton I think it's like one of those
scenarios I do think there might be a
little bit of like friction a little bit
of bad blood between Microsoft and um
and Joseph but I don't think it's like
to the point where
like there could never be a scenario
where they work together in the future
because I feel like if that was the case
after Halo Infinity he just would have
left he there's no going back he would
have just left and I I think that you
know he was unsure if he wanted to save
Microsoft that's why he just transferred
to another uh portion of the company and
I think probably sat down he's just like
look you know I did what I could and you
know it's hard to tell what happened
behind closed doors maybe Microsoft uh
maybe he fought for Halo incident in a
lot of ways we don't know because we
didn't sleep on closed doors and maybe
he didn't get what he wanted in those
kind of scenarios and maybe he's just
like look like you know I I want out and
dude's been there for how long how many
years it's like sometimes when people
leave it yeah 17. sometimes when people
leave it's just they're they're burned
out and I think you know there is a
little bit of friction between them but
I don't think it's enough where if
Microsoft hit them up way down the line
when I I think there's friction but not
enough that can't calm down you know
what I'm saying sometimes when you get
friction it's beef for life you know
what I'm saying but I don't think this
is beef for life because I feel like if
it was that he would have just left now
obviously maybe the Beast started after
he left maybe he got some repercussions
from what happened a little infinite
when he went to the other one but we
don't know because we don't have the
information on the matter but I do think
there is friction but I don't think it's
enough where you know there's going to
be like long-term beat between them I
think short term they're probably not
going to have a lot of communication but
after enough time goes by you know uh
people calm down I think there might be
communication going on maybe there's no
beef I don't know maybe they just
literally burnout they want to go and I
don't think it's that I do think there's
some little bit of friction between them
yeah yeah a little bit I think that it's
like it's like that salt dude with the
gift
it's just a little bit all right Lord
King the legendary Joseph stay leaving
Microsoft leaving Xbox but leaving
Microsoft entirely wasn't that the
golden boy that was sitting on the couch
and they called him and it was like yo
come I'm sitting on the couch who he
called them and said and he said yo I
can see you don't have no problem
he can average he saw the team was weak
yeah
I don't want to take away from Satan
like I ask you know we have heard
information that Destiny he did do a lot
to Halo Infinity I think it is yeah he
did Drake but he just dropped the 21
Savage album so nobody cares so yeah
exactly like he had to come back and
drop another album so I feel like I
heard it going to Bungie
um yeah oh yeah and I'm not an NDA dude
so yeah I heard he going to Bungie so
he'll be over there with Sony doing some
stuff over there oh that's what you
heard yeah yeah when I come out y'all
I'm gonna put on Twitter I uh here is
the NDA dudes could be pictures
it's gonna be the one where you look
like here in the Assassin's Creed you're
the next uh antagonists the protagonist
where you have like the little you know
I could probably do it here
I can't it's ridiculous it's too
ridiculous it's just listen
um you came over you did your job
fantastic one like I said either Drake
of this you can drop bad albums here and
there okay Just a Bad album
um it was a poor mix uh he thought he
can come in and save a situation and
kudos to you you probably did save it
from whatever train wreck it was and you
got into a workable uh I mean for me the
single player was lit um then what I had
right now in some of the multiplayer is
dope but um thank you for your service
um I'm not gonna go out on my [__] with
you like uh old Bonnie jump because you
know oh I really don't care
um but uh yeah body body they say come
through and that was part of the
relationship well I think I think he was
forced on the situation you know I think
when when Jordan calls and he wants to
go to the Wizards you don't say nah we
can't use them of course you know so
you're gonna let Jordan come over to the
Wizards and what happened when Jordan
went to the Wizards we all know the 45
he was out he was getting games where he
averaged but it wasn't Jordan right
right if he got shot to the playoffs
when y'all was looking Flappy and sick
man yeah yo I'm not I'm not gonna lie
I'm not issuing on them
this does not sound like an example I'm
just saying this is that's not like I am
happy
no it's I'm indifferent okay and I guess
the worst thing in life for you to be
indifferent about something it doesn't
I'm not playing Halo Halo to me right
now is dead right and it's dead in the
sense that you told me the single player
Halo infinite will evolve right you told
me that you'd be able to drop things
down in it I haven't got anything from
the initial release I haven't got any
story drops any anything any DLC nothing
for this but it's like a mini little not
enough for the story not for um
questions I wouldn't know they didn't
make a big thing about it only thing I
heard about is the the multiplayer and
you got four job y'all finished the game
that y'all was supposed to release he
did a great job getting y'all to the
Finish Line uh godspeed in your next
Endeavors okay not fair enough fair
enough look um
you know just looking at his resume man
and and for me yeah this this is big for
me you know this is obviously I'm a
destiny fan this is one of the writers
of Destiny but even before that you know
writer director of cinematics Halo
Combat Evolved I mean he's a bungee
lifer he's been there even before that
with only even two then he remembered
there was supposed to be a Halo movie
with Peter Jackson Remember Peter
Jackson from Lord of the Rings and all
that so um
get out I mean he was a creative
director on that then he's a tremendous
writer he wrote Halo 3 he wrote Halo
reach you know author of contact Harvest
he wrote addicts Halo Wars he's a big
dad Holo 300 OST rate co-corrective
director of Destiny this resume is
insane you know I mean um obviously you
know helped got off the couch helped
with uh he was a senior corrective
creative director at Microsoft and then
from there um got off the couch to kind
of helped when he heard the infinite
thing was where it was at and you know
they needed like he they could provide
his services so he's gonna have a
tremendous respect for me my whole thing
is
you know whatever state Halo was in
Prior
would be very interesting to me to find
out because there were some things we
heard that he again in a consultant role
the game's pretty much already has what
their core vision is but course
correction and then having the cashier
to be like look we need the delay I
thought that was big you know at the
time for to delay it and I feel he was
part responsible to that so you know I
was obviously we know the story the
issue ended up being the lack of uh
consistent content for the live Service
Group which is the real issue so the
vibe I got was it was all hands on deck
just to get it out the door in a in a
workable State
um to addict's point I don't know I
don't know if it's bad but because
um you know obviously the infinite thing
ended badly as far as internally people
you know obviously Bonnie and people
were fired and stuff like that you know
he then goes from talking about hey we
got more content coming and it felt like
story content it felt like they might do
this endless thing which I was super
excited for yeah that's what I wanted
because I didn't want to wait there was
a part of me the part of me that liked
infinite from a live service model was
the fact that I wouldn't have to wait
four or five years to continue my same
story like I wanted to continue let's do
this let's find out what happened with
lock that's like yesterday yeah I
thought we were going there so I'm like
okay then they don't have the content to
do it and now the person who I think
might be responsible for good writing
and good narrative and good story which
is him now leaves I'm like uh so now is
it going to be just multiplayer only
level drops yeah you know and it seems
maybe that's the case and it seems that
you know the Battle Royale you know I'm
just hoping that we get more story
content I don't have to wait for Halo 7
you know what I'm saying kind of thing
but we'll see so look legend in the game
I'm very curious to see where he goes
what the project is according to King
it'll be hey I'll be interested to see
if he goes back there that would be
interesting and or if he does what a lot
of see a lot of people do now which is
start their own project some people get
the bag it's like okay you know what I'm
gonna go over there with matter you know
yeah start to start your own joints so
salute to the legend I know more
information will come out we will see
that's King out there but absolutely it
wouldn't surprise me if you show up a
bunches though I mean
they may need his creative expertise I
mean they are doing PVP stuff we shall
see I'm very curious to see where he
goes but anyway that's what I got super
chats added from the final topic
we got a um ten dollar super trap I'm
not even but I'm not even going to
attempt man you got a 10 super strap
from an ominous Source
what are you wear D harm thread that guy
yeah stay on third there you go cause
safety because I wasn't doing it uh it's
a beautiful morning listening to the
podcast 90 on the freeway helped me it's
only about the sound just screaming at
the truck in the truck in the trunk hell
he's in the trunk oh he's in the truck
was going through then we got a uh
hilarious I don't it doesn't look like
he joined but uh Cedric H has been a
member for 33 months appreciate him and
appreciate it yes into the legendary
Centric H we good
yes we we good all right Easter Sunday
get into the last topic man
rise rise son of Rome attic this is your
topic you want me to set it up or you
good yeah you can set it though I mean
it's really straightforward you know
shout out to cry Tech the cry Tech
Twitter account couple days ago not that
long ago put up a tweet with a picture
of one of the greatest none on your P
games of all time rise of the road you
know what I'm saying they got married
who said it says a question to the realm
what fond memories do you have of Rye
sun and Rome and the journey of Marius
Titus so this set Twitter in a frenzy
why are they asking about this sequel
must be going on what's the deal so
we've been hearing these off and on but
it's the first time cry Tech has been
outside with a tweet talking about rise
to the wrong what's your memories of it
what you like it's your topic let's go
yeah it's it's interesting because you
know a rise was one of the the fan
favorites for the original x uh Xbox One
you know the big bulky one that came out
in 2000. shout out to the VCR it and I
feel like well 14 2014. I feel like
rise was this big and the kid's like
yeah
it's Easter that's turned over
somebody's bacon I'm just I'm just
sitting here thinking
what is the is this going to be a
multiply like look most likely it's
going to be a multiplayer if this is
true and I think it's true because
there's been countless spotting of rides
like explain to me how when you show
because for a while every time cry
attack has showed the job listings of
their company rise is the art that they
use for it yes why yes look look Bryce
was like like kind of a mid-sized big
game but it's not bigger than than the
Crisis crisis is the promotion that
should be on there it's like they're
teasing something and to me there's no
reason to put that on there because uh
they they make another game like a
multiplayer game I can't remember what
it's called someone in the chat put it
in there I know you guys know what I'm
talking about Obama call I'm gonna say
what's in there so to me there's all
this
on Showdown yeah uh there's all this
other artwork that you can use why use
rides and to me this is out there and it
is becoming out
part of me is like Microsoft I don't
care what you got to do oh you gotta
make sure that's the timed exclusive or
full-blown what about this call imagine
imagine if that pops up on the
PlayStation showcase and they bought
they bought that exclusive raise the
rise too I know that would be crazy
doing for that because they did that
with um the Stars they did that with
y'all Sony can do that so they can do
that so tell me how bad it's gonna be to
come out this next show and the show
sunset overdrive too
yeah that's all you covered for they
cover for Xbox well hard right there
that whoa It's possible it's possible uh
let's get kick on it let's add it get
that finished oh it was good it just
soon it comes down to it man you know
even if it's a multiplayer hell even if
it's a PlayStation exclusive I'll be
happy to see it arise too you know I'm
probably in regardless of where it's at
I would prefer it to be on Xbox but
regardless where it's at I'm still
playing yeah contact doesn't believe
only IP so that they don't have control
of it King we was there midnight
launches Xbox One there was a certain
are you going satorians fire The Archers
that was
um I think they looked at that game it
was like you know God of War can be in
his vein or whatever
um because they wanted to probably make
their own uh rise a type game
I don't care be honest with you um I've
been hearing about this for years I've
been hearing about this since like two
years after rise came out and oh you
know Microsoft needs to do this
Microsoft needs to do that something's
up with that company I don't even know
how they stand business yeah that's a
scandal there was a scandal about people
not getting paid we didn't hear the
rumors that yeah that they they do on
the IP we heard it was going to be
sequel but then nothing ever happened
yeah this is that's when Microsoft
realized uh I and I think honestly it
was them that more than any other
company made them realize owning your
own IPS and not being beholdened to a
company is uh made them go out and get
into this acquisition fever because when
your biggest game that you had visually
is owned by crytek and then you go to
crytek to try to negotiate for the next
one and cry attack is like nah you know
we don't really want to work right now B
and you like um but you know we want to
get the game out in a timely fashion and
we feel that we work well yeah right now
is not a good time um could you call me
back
[Music]
and the
Microsoft realized that they need to own
their own stuff so
I feel you on that again I just let the
game come out I feel you on that but I
do feel like this is one of those games
that it would be so much beneficial to
the Xbox brand to go out there and
correct some of the mistakes they made
in the Xbox One Edition I mean just not
you could argue that the reason they
don't have any nurturing IPS that came
from the Xbox Ones because they didn't
attend to
do you think it's smart for Microsoft to
go to these dudes that they still won't
own IP and say I'ma send you a boatload
of cash just to make sure that the IP
stays here for six months so send your
IP someplace else I don't care long as I
get a chance to have the IP run over
here let it run over there to have a
good time put it everywhere
I get what you're saying but the problem
is PlayStation got no problem doing that
we don't care about PlayStation
now the secret handheld
did you play Final Fantasy
oh my God no wait time out time out did
you play Final Fantasy which one the the
Remake yeah I still care platform just
because I played it
multiple characters
check out ten toes down you can't cry
you played it I can cry
I didn't play it at all it's over there
and I don't trust your business
practices I'm not giving you no money so
until you show up where I want you to be
then
what happened to that you said what you
gave the money for God of War if you
don't trust me platform I know it ain't
coming to Xbox
did you just make right now you said a
third party games
no no when you talk about business
practices how are you going to cherry
pick what you supporting what you think
here we go
here we go how you gonna sit there
crying
you played it so it didn't matter to you
you didn't care about crossing the
street at all you was like yo I'm going
to cry oh my God
everybody
listen you don't think I want to play it
you know I and you know Sony don't care
what stopping you what's stopping you
what's stopping me
yeah what's up with you principles
principles
I don't even know what y'all arguing
myself to go
not yet I don't know it was a hard Fire
game if they made Tekken the next tech
and right now PlayStation 6.
I know for a fact you would break that
to go play that over there okay so
basically what are we on we arguing that
I have no idea I don't know what we like
so we arguing that rise is Rises
multi-plat that Xbox so wait if
PlayStation if PlayStation if there's a
rise to a Playstation pays for
exclusivity
then that's what you say addicted that's
a bad list he's saying he's no I'm
saying that because of the Xbox one
generation and there's so much hype
going into Horizon there's so many
people that love rides on the Xbox
Korean I'm saying that it would be a
good look if they got that like a timed
exclusive King says it doesn't matter
yeah you know why it don't matter did it
sell millions when it was on Xbox
yeah I did yeah how many I don't know if
it's sold yeah listen so this is the
thing I don't know it was a launch show
hard to believe they didn't sell
millions
all right so this game didn't set the
world on fire right this this game came
out so you learn look over there for a
game that didn't set the world on fire
that is probably 10 15 years removed
that the dudes that care about it is
either gone or do something else or the
fraction of that base is there Zeitgeist
is over now yeah the game is going to
come out it's gonna do well I'm just
saying why give them money to lock it
down to your console if they want to go
multi-plat do so but here's the thing
here's the thing we can't sit there and
say when they go months and months
without any content and we say they need
to back the truck up and get some of
these timed exclusives but then when I
say that I say yo you need to get rides
it's a legacy thing you need to have
that on your platform oh why are you
giving them money nobody remember
remember last year
but let me ask you this let me ask you
this addict um what about the fact that
it is going if the rumors are true
there's supposed to be multi-platforms
too which I want to argue so you know
the um the the fact that it exists on
Xbox is not enough for you you're saying
that they should pay for it exclusive I
don't care I don't care if it goes left
or right I'm just saying perception wise
and it would be nice if they took the
the initiative to get that on there all
right so let me meet you both halfway
what if they don't do the time exclusive
that's what I'm saying what if it's a
game pass deal and it's on Playstation
but it's game one day one day I mean
that's better than having nothing but I
do get to the point where it's like they
have no problem paying for these games
past time uh timed exclusives on the on
the platform and it's just like look one
of the reasons that your competition is
doing so well is because they got no
problem going to screen to say we want
this on our stuff only they got no they
got no
to me just being on Game Pass isn't
relevant enough unless it's on certain
things but let me let me the show makes
sense because that's a big thing I can
understand that being it but at the same
time your competition's going out there
and locking down whole brands
in now In fairness to these Point their
whole bottle is Game Pass and to get
people into the subscription service and
when they have tried to lock down
exclusive titles like a rise of the Tomb
Raider right people said you shouldn't
be doing that and we're not supporting
that until the time exclusive is over
we're waiting for the PlayStation
version so when they have tried it it
hasn't necessarily worked today I feel
you but I feel like one of the reasons
that
people don't accept when they do this
because they don't do it often anymore
like the reason people have accepted
PlayStation doing it at this point is
because it's at this point just what
they do and you know the market leader
and then the market leader I I feel you
on that but people don't like them
buying Call of Duty and Activision so
like to me just because Twitter versus
in that small minority people don't like
it don't mean you shouldn't do it
of the people that you think care about
this game being locked down to the Xbox
console matter I'm being real with you
uh the Casual don't really give a hell
if you game over here your game over you
play it if it's going in Game Pass when
they go in Game Pass it's a game all
right so it's not uh tied to the Xbox
brand when Xbox was trying to negotiate
and trying to buy this game right they
didn't want to sell right so now you
think you're gonna go over there for for
a chick that don't want to mess with you
go back over there and tell her now hold
on you think you're gonna go back over
there and tell her yo listen so let's
date exclusively for six months and then
you're gonna go over no I'm not giving
you no bread you didn't want to mess
with me back then when you mess with me
on my platform you did not go over there
to the other platform so it only made
sense for you for you to mess with me
again and then you didn't and it was all
these excuses and it's all this stuff
hey how about we buy each studio now how
about we buy the IP nah so now the game
is going to come out and it's going to
be on multiply that means you wanted to
go multiply from the beginning you
regretted the fact that you dated me
solo to begin with the fact that you you
regretted that you dated me solo you
want to be for the streets I'm not going
over there trying to put a ring on your
fingers
you look at something like
rice in a room looks like it's gonna be
multi-flat look at something like you
know uh Alan Wake two original was an
XBox exclusive multiplayer you look at
something like this uh
XBox exclusive
to me it's not it's not about whether or
not one of these games is about games
that was originated on the Xbox platform
Microsoft isn't trying to pursue but
PlayStation right has no problem there
is literally a rail where you can have a
PlayStation showcase where they show
Sunset Overdrive two rice Center and
it's all marketed or exclusive
like you're sitting there having these
games you're having these showcases and
these fans that played these games on
other platforms and like it's either
your stuff is Marketing Online oh it's
my I feel you and this is where I'm with
you and King because at that the Xbox
one generation to prove that they don't
have ownership there you go they don't
have they learn the hard reality that
you can't control where that chick go
she's gonna do whatever she gonna do so
I'm with you it looks horrible when you
see it from an Xbox Optics perspective
and I it looks terrible that I'll wake
over there this one Mass Effect is now
over there they had all these underneath
their roof at one point right you're
right look I'm a jumper this is fun yeah
I made the show long I was trying to go
quick
y'all arguing but this is fun so look
greatest 900p game of all time let's be
clear right I want to give crytek they
flowers I know we go hard on them the
cry engine at that time what they were
doing at that time on a gimped Xbox one
that was still utilizing the connect
remember y'all the connect was still
Bumble bundled in that launch that was
taking that 10 of power that they
eventually was able to remove and they
get gangs to try to be 1080P or whatever
whatever D these dudes was magicians
they was doing the Lord's work I would
never forget that trailer at the Xbox
One showcase forget about the other
stuff with the TV TV deal I'm talking
about the game showcase I still on this
day feel the Xbox One launch lineup was
superior to the PlayStation 4 lineup
they had rice on the run that looked
like the greatest thing I've ever seen
you talk about Quantum break kind of in
the window you talk about Sunset
Overdrive kind of into the window Killer
Instinct Forza then a Titanfall one kind
of into that first year of Xbox One and
the reason why I go so hard for hashtag
just one is because rise was a hashtag
yeah Quantum break was a hashtag just
one it was a new IP new character New
Generation New Generation experience I'm
with you at it saddened me that we ain't
get no rides too you know what I'm
saying and I was like why is that then I
find out oh they are on control
damn y'all I was like yeah like man I
don't own that and to me that birth
filled into 2018 which is you know what
we can't go through this again you know
what here Ninja Theory compulsion games
um Mo Yang uh playground games
because they when they lost that too it
was all of that stuff that they but
that's their phone on Call of Duty
though
yeah the thing though when it comes to
this is like I'm not saying you know go
out there and snatch this go out there
and snatch that I'm saying like do a
PlayStation does still nurture Your
Studios but you know if the game makes
sense go out there and get all right if
they remember you you acted as if two
people have to agree
they haven't done it right because I
don't know what they've done I'm just
saying if they haven't went out there I
feel like that's a mistake the rumors
are that they have tried to negotiate a
rise to for a long time since the days
we had kissable talk about this you know
saying so the rumors all they have but
if you don't own it there's only so much
negotiation you could do if she wouldn't
be for the streets and she don't want to
deal with you and say yo the numbers on
that launch
yep was not what we thought after all
this effort we made on this greatest
looking down if he came and y'all so I'm
just making you guys need to calm down
about me being heated in the chat no
this is just I don't see that bad like
that that's not something this is just
regular stuff it's ridiculous I can be
heated and show you straight out of the
channel
no we're good this is regular regular
stuff that's not a lord talk you know
everybody's good don't worry about this
so at the end of the day like they
learned that and it's like yo they ain't
gonna rock with us you know I don't care
what you do kind of energy kind of thing
then it's like okay it's gonna be
multiplied now this is what I'm with you
I would at minimum would like to see
them off of The Game Pass back if they
take it because at least even if it's
multi-plat it almost feels like it's for
free you know what I'm saying over on
then that that to me is the happy I
think me it's just a I don't even care
to be honest with you I think it just it
would look for a good perception wise
like you have a show oh yeah and it's
like you know what they they low-key
going out there and they're like look we
know the Xbox
let down to a lot of people we're gonna
let you off with this rice on a row two
exclusively on our platform like it
don't really have to be everything man
it's not like I'm saying go out there
and get everything I'm saying that Rice
Center Rope 2 has a lot of meaning to a
lot of people of course I am with you it
means a lot like you tell me we go watch
the Showcase this week and at the end
you see right and you hear
and you see right the Xbox tears grow
man eyes tears grown man
from IG and itself
from the Xbox one generation look I'm
with you all both of y'all are right
both things can't exist you could be
right how it means to the Xbox thing but
King could be right in the sense that yo
if they be like yo it's still coming but
it's game pack we got y'all we got the
you know exclusive Game Pass deal we
going it's going to be on our platform
and we wanted it for you guys you know
both can still coexist the last thing I
was just gonna say that's what I want
because I didn't get my balls off
because I was fighting
um you know look the qte we understand
but you got to be real Combat this time
fam you gotta be real Combat this time
yeah you got to call you got a god award
this you gotta you know whatever because
the combat was fired now I would Kindle
I want the qte as like
dude the regular Calvin dude every
Calvin dude got a QT no no no we need to
cut them up like certain situations
when you fight like big bosses in God of
War they let you see qte them that's I
wouldn't do it like seafood yes yes
big moments only big moments and not
every do only the Epic type joints I
want that
um these people are ridiculous don't
kick us out adding is the most manly man
I'm not kicking you out guys you're
saying so I want that um as far as the
um remember forget people forget destroy
had Co-op
um the co-op I want to see what it was
very underrated and the story the story
was dope we learned about the damn it
cleaves the dark era you know what I'm
saying the Republic Vibe so look
hopefully the rule I think these rumors
are true I'm not even gonna hold you I
think this is really true there's too
much smoke for it to be fired I'm
pulling for it and then the last thing
which is solves topic anybody saw the um
ID Xbox showcase just real quick okay so
I saw it
um for me the last thing I had oh I want
to shout out last case of Benedict Fox
it looked really good again oh yeah I
actually sent them an interview oh
that's what's up yeah I sent them a a an
email about an interview that I'm trying
to do with the writers yeah I never got
back to them because it was that past
when they got me yeah I saw that Pax
West it looked phenomenal I saw that and
then y'all vampire survivors King new
DLC looking really good oh yeah
I can't wait for that that's gonna be
dope yeah dude Jay like that I mean the
rest of the games really wasn't for me
the games that I was looking for was
Planet Lana and replaced it wasn't there
but look you know shout out to ID and
Xbox teams that you know you know people
they're working still working they're
still doing their thing and they really
have done their job on the NDC yeah you
know when the PlayStation used y'all
threw y'all to the bushes Microsoft
because remember that that PlayStation 4
didn't have it'd be stationed it was the
Indie station y'all everything Indy we
over here we love you Indies as soon as
they got that one AAA Banger they
changed your passcode you couldn't get
in the building oh my God
what it is they pick the right it needs
to make exclusive yeah yeah now they
choosy
now it's a line in the club when you get
there you're like oh it's a bouncer
we always walk in this club and now it's
a bouncer in the front second wristbands
what what wait wait a second wristband
like yeah you got to wait oh my God
you are ridiculous anyway the dress code
now for the club so that's all I got on
this Easter Sunday I think when we get
to the uh poor what you want me doing
you want me you want to do something
okay so shout out to everybody in the
community
um yeah so with the news and rumors all
these new handhelds emerging which of
these have has you the most excited a
the Asus rap rock Allied the steam that
killer
Kings
PS5 Remote Play handheld
yeah you know clap the clap okay
see for attic a new Switch potentially
broke
or D I don't care I need this Xbox
handheld or else those aren't the
choices oh shout out to Tom headers to
the 200 I'll queue like I feel that I'm
feeling here I love you bro I can't not
wait though you know slide into me those
are the choices and this time I will
remember to put the poll up so apologies
that was a l on [__] last week we had
all these technical issues that I was
trying to figure out so we got to sort
it out but uh yeah I appreciate y'all in
the room attic won't get this super chat
before with your face bro why you got
that face yeah I mean look at all these
I don't know if we had one okay just
double check make sure it turned out
okay yeah so we have people complaining
about me yeah yes let's go let's read
those all right let me
all right let me look at these all right
so the last one we read okay so we got a
two dollar Super Chat
with a no five dollar super strap from
black Ronin
what do you say okay no he got that one
five dollar super trap for max if you
flip the script no we got that one too
okay and then we got the five dollar
Super Chat from uh blackron and Sony
will be mad if I become the okay hold on
let me I gotta be behind on this like
the super chats the thing is weird
because like if you don't refresh
refresh it doesn't show me the newer
stuff this is where we we would
definitely miss our stuff all right
there we go because he when he does he
copies it down yeah
oh man they a lot of people actually
super Chatters right let's get him flip
the script okay yeah ten dollar super
trap for Max
uh Saudi trying to uh Regulators with
not being able to survive if the deal
goes through which we would know true
okay I read that uh harjushini I read
that
um two dollars uh five ten dollars Super
Chat from
it's a beautiful thing listening to no
I've read that and then two dollars to
project from Spartan dose hey a little
bit mad none but elves goodbye to that
dude okay and then we got a five dollar
Super Chat from rezio hold on let's be
honest Xbox turned down uh core tour
remake we can't blame people without
evidence that's right with people
without evidence I'm just going off the
information I have which is none uh you
know regardless how you guys feel about
that that's fine it's just I'm telling
you you've off the information that I
have I think it would be a very big
disappointment if they didn't reach out
to them okay
okay so uh yeah that's all did we get
any merchandise so no I didn't see any
any do me a favor put the one of the
shirts in plug that in right quick you
know how you did with the little alert
drink so they could see the joint so I
could plug it at the bottom of the
episode remember you did that last time
yeah my computer always be like I don't
worry about it if you can't you can't
don't worry about it but look wrapping
this up man again appreciate y'all on
the Easter Sunday a little shorter show
than normal I know but uh yeah think
things people gotta take care of things
today and solve you know we had to set
our love to solve
had to go spend time with the family but
look we appreciate y'all
he wasn't feeling well again appreciate
uh shout out to the legendary Tom
Henderson pull it up I've never seen Tom
Anderson on podcast so very honored to
have him in the realm and we will have
him back we'll talk we're talking about
unboxing for the unboxing for you or the
Q Light release yeah
no that's what we do and then we'll give
them the Royal Treatment also we'll get
that going so um Lord attic where can
the front people find you what you got
going on sir
you can find me on Twitter at Lord
addict IOP you can find me on YouTube
gaming ad it's going to be streaming uh
Zelda tomorrow Ocarina of Time hey I'm
gonna do like some streaming for the
rest of the month going into uh you know
tears of the Kingdom yeah we're really
hoping they came it's gonna blow my
socks off you know currently I have
socks on so I hope it blows them off
we'll just sucks
I do I do I want it I want that game
like that man I want it like that and
then you know I'm gonna play through all
of Ocarina time I think Majora's Mask
you know I've only beat Majora's Mask
twice in my entire life I don't remember
much of anything uh so it's going to be
interesting going through that game
again because I have almost zero
knowledge at this point you know like
certain things go a certain amount of
time goes by you just don't remember
nothing like you watch a movie and
you've seen like 15 years you don't
remember nothing about the movie so I'm
excited to play that unfortunately
nothing else is on there or I play like
Wind Waker and stuff but tomorrow
probably probably around noonish I'm
going to play Zelda Ocarina time on my
uh of my YouTube channel gaming addicts
I hope you guys come through you know
put no don't you can keep your shoes on
you know because I know I know
I know King over there want you guys
shoes on I don't think we got to be that
intimate he would cry but what's going
on but I'm pretty sure we're coming
through and uh we had up to like 750
people in here you know I come through
every week I'm glad you guys really
enjoyed now next week like I said you
know we we have a very big show for you
guys don't forget that uh you know I
hope you guys enjoy next week we're
gonna we're gonna have a pretty killer
show there's my link to my YouTube
channel in the description tomorrow 12
p.m I will be starting to play Ocarina
of Time no doubt no doubt salute Lord
King where can I do find you what you
got going on you can find me on Twitter
King David OTW uh same one for my uh
Xbox uh gamertag
I think it's uh put you on Playstation I
think it's Xbox game pass lover
something crazy because I had to change
my joints only got me you know because
it was three uh Xbox 360 level one and
they got me so I had to change my joint
but it's like Xbox game pass lover
you're not gonna stop me
like me
that ecosystem whack anyway oh
follow me uh and uh addict uh r r with
the Lords on Tuesday
we're going to talk about uh a knock at
the cabin oh
um I still gotta watch that yeah yeah
you do so get on that knock at the cabin
uh Mario
and what else it was something else
I know I gotta watch the mandalorians
yeah yeah um other than that you know I
I know y'all enjoying the Star Wars
stuff for the past couple of days Star
Wars was lit that was the great stuff
that was going on over there a lot of
information came out I know a lot of you
guys were disappointed we're gonna talk
about that too yeah yeah that's kind of
crazy
um but yo listen go see Mario if you
didn't see Mario oh cocaine beard is
coming to Peacock so if you didn't get a
chance to see cocaine being in the
movies go check it out when it lands on
peacock peacock is the place to see all
your slasher films this is the dopest
flasher film that doesn't care about
pushing an agenda it's just crazy no
doubts with everybody in the room let me
get a dragon heart Yobe man but for 21
months he said
um Lord gold peace love and life keep up
the great work and it's always mad love
AK I appreciate your means what's the
ETO and the king of statues podcast
peace kid oh that's coming soon
um also everybody
you have valori pillows is uh should be
landing in your home a lot of people
have been posting that they got their
pillows on Soul shoes so uh check your
emails for everybody that's supported
and they got out there and if you came
to Paxton you got a chance to see the
pillows in person yo y'all know what it
is so uh definitely listen to everybody
that's it on Twitter man post the
pillows post them pillows show us that
pillow
be sure you attack us all attack Volari
don't forget the time at the Villari I'm
putting the link in there for anybody
who missed out you know I mean the link
I'm putting the link up in the
description and all that but um yeah use
cold war 15 get that 15 off we're seeing
the pillows in the wild I saw a kid
smooth I saw a fave 2K you know what I'm
saying and a lot of people getting them
now so run away Dragon 108 oh shout out
the one away had an amazing
shout out to Boom you know what I'm
saying so we're gonna see we're starting
to see people they're popping up in a
while we'll put that Volari up if it
came through go check that out let us
know what you think and uh yeah for me
you already know like a new yo like
addict said uh next week the big one
episode
300 300 episodes of IOP we're very
excited about that should be a fun and a
Big Show and I retire after next week
300 you know when we first started this
the contract I gave to cogs at 300. I
said man we gotta gotta see what we're
going to do with an extension or not but
anyway
but anyway look enjoy your Easter and
again appreciate y'all here on the
Easter Sunday this was love we up out of
here anything else boys I am sending you
guys over there to wandering Dutch go
there show them some love okay
go go in there man put put in that chest
spam that chat with IOP sent you and I
appreciate everyone for you guys doing
it that's it and then I know we about it
here
thank you
[Music]
foreign